make your calendar your life this is how
you start to live in intentional life
because you've designed it you've put it
in your calendar not just the business
things when we think about a calendar
it's usually your business stuff okay I
got a meeting here I gotta send my
newsletter out whatever the things are
for your business life if you're an
entrepreneur you probably have some of
your business things put in your
calendar I'm not talking just about that
I'm talking about your life talking
about how do you live an intentional
Life by structuring every day what ends
up happening inside of that is oh my
gosh that's too much structure I can't
stick to it it's too overwhelming I need
free time great put free time in your
calendar if you know that you need two
hours a week to have nothing in your
calendar this is how you reduce stress
and anxieties because you've actually
scheduled in your two hour break and
nothing else comes in because when you
don't schedule your break here's what
happens other things are going to come
up as a priority other people's
emergencies what happens you lead back
down to stress anxiety overwhelm you
block off your time you build your ideal
life need motivation watch top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
in my first business I quit on my
business partner I was making 300 bucks
a month and I didn't have the motivation
to keep going and the thing that got me
through was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from me and my team's
take on my top 10 rules of success
enjoy
I was talking to entrepreneur yesterday
who I'm mentoring and he he his business
blowing up
his business is blowing up it's amazing
um on his way to seven Figures it's
crazy
and he's struggling with his health
going to doctor's appointments
struggling has lots of inflammation and
I suppose you okay so you need to you
need to eat better you need to work out
more you need to have a kind of healthy
lifestyle you you already know this I'm
not telling you anything new
but it's on his calendar so we loaded
his calendar and his calendar is all of
his business stops like okay well where
are you where is the physical activity
in your calendar and where are you
prepping for the meals that you're going
to eat because when you just show up on
a good morning hey have a great day
awesome okay now you're really hungry
there's nothing healthy in the fridge
what do you do you go for you go for
junk or you go do takeout
because you didn't plan because it
wasn't in your calendar
you need to schedule it you need to
schedule when you're going to go buy
food if you're going to order out how
many times a week do you want to order
out like schedule this stuff in as Jocko
willing says discipline equals freedom
you want this life it's entirely
possible
but you have to have the discipline in
your calendar to actually follow through
on it
when you find yourself not following the
calendar
it's because of a couple reasons the
first is because
you set goals that are not actually
possible there wasn't enough flexibility
in your calendar right that you say how
many times you've set a goal and said
I'm going to work out every day for for
two hours and then and then what happens
you don't because it's unrealistic
because it's not gonna happen
and what you're also doing is training
yourself that you suck that when you set
goals that you don't follow through
that's a problem
then the next time you set a goal you're
gonna
tell yourself oh I'm not going to do
this one either because I always set
goals and don't follow through you don't
you stop believing in yourself it's not
even other people believing in you you
don't believe in yourself because you've
taught yourself that when you do some
when you say you're gonna do something
you don't actually do it that's a
problem
so how do we start to fix that we start
to fix that by actually creating a
calendar that reflects her entire life
so think about your goals let's let's
break this down right step one think
about the life that you want what's the
life that you want how much time do you
want to spend sleeping how much time do
you want to spend with family how much
time do you want to spend this will
change right if your husband wife single
kids anybody sick in your family those
will shift our calendar accordingly but
right now think about your life right
now how much time do you want to spend
with your family how much time you want
to spend in your business how much you
want to how much time you want to spend
do you need for yourself
free time or meditation time or working
out time or going out in nature time how
much time do you want to spend planning
that as opposed to randomly hoping that
your day happens as you want it it's not
having no plan and no schedule is the
path to stress and overwhelm
having a decent plan even a poor plan at
the beginning starts to create the
momentum that you need so think about
how much time you want to spend in those
categories because you don't want to
spend all day sleeping you don't you
don't want to spend all day with your
family you don't want to spend all day
with your kids with your husband wife
you don't want to spend all day working
you don't want to spend all day relaxing
either like the idea of work sitting on
the beach might be great right now
because you feel stressed overwhelmed
and may hate your life but you don't
want to spend all day every day at a
beach you would get so bored the trick
is not to escape your current life
because then you're going back to it
right so Escape for two weeks the life
that you hate to then come back to it
the trick is to build a better life and
it starts with an intentional calendar
so think about how much time you want to
spend on the different categories
then step two I would split it up
between things that you need to do daily
and things you need to do either on a
weekly or monthly basis so daily is
daily routine so I have a morning
routine I'll wake up I'll put on music
I'll set the intention for the day I'll
go for a walk outside it's the snowing
in Toronto this morning I still go for
my walk outside I'll do some kind of
workout whether it's swimming or yoga
some kind of workout and then I'll start
my day
right what I do is start my day like my
business day those are different days of
the week okay so just do morning routine
and then evening routine so we bucket
these but these are mostly the same
every day evening routine
I'll eat dinner with Nina at six I have
blocked off an hour to be able to spend
time with her at seven I'll stream on my
gaming YouTube channel answering
questions from you at eight I'll spend
time with my son Hayden usually playing
Minecraft or catching up or doing
something together nine will sit down
and watch a show with Nina right now
we're watching Wheel of Time on Amazon
10 I'll take the dogs out I'll come back
up I'll clean the dishes and whatever
else needs to be cleaned in the condo 11
o'clock I'm getting ready for bed
reading the book and hopefully passing
out right evening routine pretty
structured pretty similar every day
what it does is make sure I have time
for all the stuff I want to have time
with my son I want to have time with my
wife I want to have time to eat dinner
and not be stressed out and rush into
the next thing I want to make sure that
there's still time to do family admin
stuff like take the dogs out and clean
the place because
sure if I miss it one day everything
would be fine but if every day I'm not
taking the dogs out and not clean up the
place that's going to cause strain on my
relationship with Nina and also not
being happy with myself right so all
these things are designed now that
structure may sound overwhelming and
crazy for you awesome you have different
goals maybe you need four hours of open
time every night or four hours of
meditation time every night don't don't
take my calendar I'm just giving you an
example you need to create your calendar
for yourself
so what's your daily morning routine and
daily evening routine put it down create
it
then inside of the week you might have
different different things on different
days I structured my entire day so
Monday's mentoring day I just mentored
my team Tuesday is YouTube day where i'm
filming content today's a Tuesday I
don't know when the video comes out for
you but for me I'm filming on a Tuesday
Wednesday is my project day it's totally
open to work on projects that I want to
work on Thursdays public facing dates
interviews podcasts shows Etc so Tuesday
Thursdays are busy this I'm not being
creative I'm just work work work work
work work work work work very little
free time
and I'm doing tons of videos and tons of
interviews Wednesday in the middle is
totally open
like okay all the ideas that I've had
all the projects that I've wanted to do
here's my time in my calendar to do it
because if I didn't have that spot then
I would feel again stressed out
overwhelmed I feel like I'm just
answering all these
messages and just creating content and
just going on people's shows and I have
no time to create my own stuff perfect
Wednesdays Done Right Wednesdays I would
use to write my book
the whole day totally open Friday's my
CEO day
where I work on the business instead of
in the business Saturday is fun day
so Saturday if I'm doing anything that's
work related has to be cleared through
Nina first and better be something big
so I lose out on some opportunities
because Saturdays is fun day and then
Sunday is family at midday cleaning up
the condo grocery shopping
Costco whatever whatever needs to get
done that's my life
right that fits for me let me be the
total worst thing for you it probably is
awesome figure out your life
morning routine evening routine your
entire life not just what you need to do
as an entrepreneur for your business but
for your life as a husband or a wife or
a son or a daughter or a parent your
life time you need for yourself
create it
morning routine evening routine and then
the rest of the week what are you gonna
do it matters this is how you start to
build consistent habits
the next step is to
evaluate at the end of the week how well
you did the whole point isn't to beat
yourself up of how you sucked and how
you missed this and schedules don't work
for you Etc but to evaluate it's not
that you can't stick to a schedule is
that the schedule wasn't a good enough
schedule for you
so what needs to change in the schedule
for example for dinner for me
these are these micro tweaks you might
have to make a big tweak but a micro
trick for me was I had my dinner from 5
30 to 6 with Nina
and it just felt too rushed I said okay
well we don't usually take an hour to
eat we eat small meals so we usually eat
it pretty quickly
um so okay half an hour perfectly easy
enough time
but it kind of felt rushed getting into
it so even though it doesn't take us a
full hour to eat I book off an hour to
eat that's an example of a micro
adjustment so think about where do you
feel stressed out in your calendar
you've done it for a week right you plan
out your calendar for the next week
perfect morning routine eating routine
what happens during the week during the
day perfect you evaluate at the end of
the week where did you feel stressed
where did it not work out
where did you miss something
and if it's a one-off thing okay fine
something happened but if it's happening
consistently
then your calendar is broken
then you need to spend more time here if
you get to the end of the week and you
feel stressed out overwhelmed what are
you feeling feeling oh I don't have
enough time to myself this is what the
the person I was mentoring yesterday
said like I look at your calendars I
couldn't do that I have no time to
myself
great scheduling time to yourself
because if you don't schedule in time
for yourself chances are something's
going to jump on top of it and you'll
never have time for yourself I'm giving
you the answer
so where's time for yourself
oh Saturday morning perfect how much
time you need four hours Great put that
in give yourself five hours as a buffer
just in case now you got the time
and protect that time
so it's making those micro adjustments
as you go until your first week if
you've never done this or feels
overwhelming or stressed for you the
first week is probably going to be a
disaster that's okay
you did some of the things that's better
than not doing any of the things so
let's make some progress now at the end
of the week look back and iterate
change it make some micro tweaks okay
that clearly didn't work here okay so
next week I'm going to try doing this
and what you do is get closer and closer
and closer to creating a schedule that
actually fits for who you are for your
goals and it's not going to be my
schedule it's not going to be Steve
Jobs's schedule or Jordan Peterson
schedule anybody else it's gonna be one
that you design tailored for you and
then the third last step to it is you're
going to grow and change as a person and
your schedule needs to change and adjust
alongside so there's a very big
difference between having a job and
being an entrepreneur there's also a
difference between being a solo
entrepreneur and then having a team does
it even having five people on your team
or one person to five people to 37
people now for me there's a big
difference in how I need to manage my
time I didn't I have a whole day
dedicated to mentoring I didn't need
that when it's just me
right things have to change if you're
you're single versus in your
relationship or single versus engaged
versus married and how long have you
been married
or if you have kids or not or planning
to have kids right like your your
choices will change as you change as a
human so even if you create the perfect
schedule right now for yourself and
that's reflective of today like it's a
perfect schedule for this week right now
chances are in a couple months you're
gonna have to make some micro tweaks
because something's changed in your life
and that's okay that doesn't mean that
your schedule sucks just means it needs
an evolution as you evolve your schedule
has to evolve with you
you are what you consistently do and the
way to become that person that you want
to build the life that you want it's not
just having some
vision board for yourself
is by actually putting into your
calendar let your calendar be your
bucket list
that if you start actually living this
life and doing these things it leads to
a happy whole life for you
treat your personal
just as important as your business
everything gets put into the calendar
and then adjust
and now you're building a life that you
want rule number two love what you do
the number one rule for success is you
have to love what you do you have to
love the process of the thing that you
are doing I've studied more successful
people than most people in the work that
I've done on my YouTube channel my
website before that that's been 20 years
when did I start doing this I was 20
22 when I started
teaching
how you can model success for your own
success right that was through my
website and I'm I'm 41 and a half now so
almost 20 years of doing this 20 years
of studying the most successful people
and trying to dissect their lessons and
bring them out for you to enjoy
and the number one rule that I found
over and over and over and over and over
again the people who achieve at the
highest levels whether you're an
entrepreneur you're an inventor you're
an athlete you are a musician you are an
artist the number one rule
is that you love the thing the actual
thing not just the results of what you
get not just accomplishing the gold
medal or getting the thing that's on
your dream board getting that house or
getting that car not that the actual
work so it doesn't feel like work you
know that old expression of uh find
something you love and you never work a
day in your life and it's really true I
look at my calendar and I see what I've
got to do uh every day I've got to make
videos it doesn't feel like work you
know I don't look at this like how lucky
am I to be able to make videos in the
car and that's my work day right
a lot of people would step into my life
and hate this great you know I would
step into a lot of people's lives and
hate that too
that's the challenge when you're
stepping into somebody else's life or
your or you're helping somebody else
build their dream and you don't actually
like the process of what you're doing
you're not going to be happy first of
all and you're not going to be
successful either you're always going to
know that you're capable of more doing
something bigger something better and as
long as you you're stuck with your foot
on the brake
you're gonna know you're capable of more
on just being too afraid to go chase
down the potential so the number one
rule for success is you have to love
what you're doing I was doing a
presentation yesterday Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit and it's
probably the biggest event every year
for people who want to become
influencers thought leaders experts get
their message out to the world you know
my kind of people you got a message you
want to share with the world let's go
and I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem
and and I can't reach everybody but you
can like you can reach people that I
can't reach with your message and so I
love you and we'll try to help spread
the techniques and strategies the
motivation as well the belief that you
have a power of a voice and getting that
out there to the world so yesterday I'm
I'm doing my one hour talk with Brendan
uh and
I shared my graphic of my growth over
the years and it's it was really slow
growth at the beginning
very little results uh you know 60
subscribers or whatever to 100
subscribers you know I'm on year five
and I'm still still in the four figures
of subscribers and it took a long time
for me to get out of my own way it took
a long time for me to get comfortable in
front of the camera it took a long time
for me to feel like my story meant
anything had any kind of value like why
do you want to learn from me when I'm
you could learn from Oprah or
Elon Musk or Bill Gates or whoever the
person is took a long time
and they've done now
I don't know how many thousands of
videos or over 10 000 videos that we've
made
and so somebody asked him well like how
do you keep going how did you keep going
when you had no results at the beginning
when you weren't
becoming famous or you weren't getting a
lot of feedback or recognition and how
did you make so many videos
so consistently right if you average
that out that's that's over a thousand
videos a year
we make over a thousand videos a year
sounds crazy just thinking about that
that's three videos a day every day for
12 years
it's pretty crazy how do you how do you
maintain that level of consistency and
not burn out where some people are
burning out after six months of being on
YouTube
well I love what I did
right I always focused on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't because
the who you're not serving game
never ends you know if my main channel
has three million subscribers why does
it have four or five or seven or ten or
40 right that game is never ending
but if you focus on who you are serving
who you are helping who is paying
attention who is valuing from the
product Services content you're creating
it makes you feel better
because focus on who you're not serving
puts you in a position of
attack right of like you're not good
enough
people don't care and it starts to take
a knock on your self-worth but when you
focus on who you're actually helping and
serving and that somebody got value from
your your message today your product
your service today it gives you extra
motivation to keep going like how do you
persevere it's because you feel like
you're doing something that matters
if you woke up and felt like today
didn't matter you're not likely to stay
very consistent right it's like if
nobody's nobody's gonna watch nobody's
gonna care nobody's gonna buy my thing
well what reason you had to get up and
go work on that thing you're probably
gonna quit but when you feel like it
matters even if it's to one person
that what you're gonna make today will
matter will mean something to even just
one person if you actually felt that
you're gonna show up completely
differently than if you felt like it
didn't matter
so I always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't
and then the second part to that was I
actually enjoy the process of doing it
you know so when I see filming day on my
calendar or when I see interview day on
my calendar
it's not work it's not like okay I gotta
go to work and then I'm gonna have fun
afterwards
when I get asked that on uh on podcast
how many hours do you work
or how do you how do you stay so
consistent on the content
I respond with well I'm here talking to
you on your show
is this work for you because it's not
worked for me this is fun for me
it might be considered work I guess to
it's my business it's part of business
time but it doesn't feel like work
the days fly by because I'm enjoying
the actual work of what's going on I
enjoy the process and I think that's the
key and when you find the people who who
have had tremendous success you'll find
that they actually
enjoy the things they're doing and that
the days fly by
and it's a good sign s not you know like
if your day is not flying by if you're
stuck and you're struggling doing
something
chances are that's the wrong thing for
you
that's the thing that you need to give
up on as soon as possible and maybe that
means you need to quit on the whole
business like if the whole business is
giving nothing but stress and problems
and you don't want to go in and you
don't want to work on it anymore maybe
you pick the wrong business maybe you
you did what most people do is they pick
an opportunity just because they think
it's a hot business because it's a
trending
industry to be in for this year but if
you don't actually ever like the thing
you're going to quit on it and you
should quit on it so you can go find
something that you actually love right
so if you pick the business just for the
opportunity
because you think you're gonna make a
quick buck
you're gonna hate your life get out of
it ASAP or it might mean there's just
little bits inside the business that you
don't want to do
and maybe you have to do it
and you have to do it for now until you
can afford to hire someone to do it or
maybe it just doesn't have to get done
you know maybe maybe that's not required
you know there's some things that have
to get done that you might not enjoy
right filing taxes
most people don't enjoy filing taxes
most entrepreneurs that I've met do not
enjoy filing taxes as as a part of their
business but if you don't want to be in
trouble with the government then you
have to file your taxes you know it's
important part of being an entrepreneur
and so maybe the beginning you do it
yourself but as quickly as you can you
want to hand that off to somebody else
to do let them do it because they love
it and they're great at it and it allows
you more time but also just mental
energy because
it's not just about the hours worked
when you are working on something that
you do not enjoy doing at all that two
hours feels like 20 hours
can you relate you know like doing two
hours of work that you hate feels like
it took an entire week to do of mental
energy versus when you're actually
having fun doing it and it doesn't feel
like work you could keep going and
you're you're producing so much and time
just seems to fly by
so use that negative time as a filter
so when you feel that way that you're
not happy you look at your calendar and
you're not happy about what's coming up
that's a that's a great time
for the awareness to shift something
needs to shift
if you look at your calendar you can do
this homework right now look at your
calendar see what's coming up in the
next two weeks
is it exciting for you are you pumped to
go do it or are you dreading it or
apathetic towards it like you could take
it or you could leave it
and if there's nothing that's exciting
in your calendar nothing that scares you
in your calendar in a good way like it's
growth opportunity then you need to add
something in and if you're constantly
dreading or hating the stuff that is in
your calendar you need to get out of
that because you will never win doing
work that you hate
people say that you know do whatever it
takes you won't not consistently not for
a sustained period of time you could do
anything in a short amount of time but
over over years decades you won't you
won't stay consistent on doing something
that you hate you'll never win because
you're going up against people who love
it
whatever Market you're in
if you don't love it
and it's just a strategy for you
and somebody else your competition loves
it they they live it they eat it they
breathe it they bleed it they love it
that's them and for you just a strategy
and you hate it who do you think's gonna
win in the long term
it's not going to be you
but meanwhile there is something you
could dive into that you could love
the actual work not just the results but
the actual work
and you have to find it
I've studied so many successful people
over the almost 20 years now 19 and a
half years of doing this
and the reason why I went to
non-entrepreneurs as well
was because it's all the same lessons
that success in athletics and success in
music and success in art and success in
every field
still comes down to
you need to love the process
love the work
and if that's you and you love what
you're doing you have to keep going and
find a way to make it work or you'll
regret giving up on it
and if you're the opposite and you hate
what you're doing you think it's good
strategy
the best strategy is to get out and go
find something that you love because
that's where you will win rule number
three get tough self-confidence comes
from doing difficult things
self-confidence self-love self-respect
it all comes from deciding to do
something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it it's too hard it's too
difficult it's too scary
most people let you off the hook the
people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know like that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry you can't
see we had like you see some here behind
me it's like look at see that mountain
of snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rocking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like oh I could look out the
window and say ah so much snow I'm not
gonna do that I'll do it when there's
less snow you know and then the next day
there's less snow there's still snow in
the next it's still snow and then all of
a sudden you just gave up on the Habit
right like you let yourself off the hook
to say I'll do it tomorrow and then and
then you never do it and then the
habit's gone and that's what you're
teaching yourself this is why it leads
to Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
going to do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious no like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me I don't
have to walk through that much but but
up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters through this thing
and initially my thought was
oh man why is there no path why is
nobody shoveled this why has nobody
still Blowfish like gotta get over there
I got a backpack on I'm rocking I'm
sweating like crazy I'm already
exhausted now I gotta go through this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort admin would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snow to
your knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating a path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so
that now they will have not an easy time
but an easier time of crossing the same
path
so they can get across
so it's going to serve us
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
on my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships in your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway
because it's scary and it makes your
heart race right don't be stupid but
most of the things that you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of the people
you will never do anything great you
will never live your great life because
somebody always has a plan for what you
should be doing with your life you will
never please everybody it's not possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason I do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and
rule number four trust your ideas great
ideas flow through you teach yourself to
learn to understand to feel that great
ideas flow through you that when you are
feeling bold powerful courageous
ambitious an idea comes to you that is
the right perfect idea for you right now
and don't let your head talk you down
from doing it I think most of us live
small I think I think we're constantly
living small we're so concerned about
our friends telling us that our ideas
suck it's us
it's ourselves it's you telling yourself
that your idea sucks that you can never
do that we feel great one day this is
the entrepreneur roller coaster right
you feel great one day oh my God this is
such a great idea I could go do this
this is amazing and maybe you start
taking some action on it but then what
immediately happens is your head starts
taking over say well you I mean you
can't do that because you you don't have
the school the education the parents the
connections you live in the wrong
country you're the wrong gender race Etc
and then and then it stops
meanwhile dummies are winning off of
your idea with less heart with less
drive with less ambition with less of a
desire to do good they're winning off of
your idea because they went off and did
something while you are stuck
overthinking your idea this is what we
do this is what entrepreneurs especially
the the heart
centered ones do
stock constantly over analyzing
overthinking and stuck in the mud
instead of actually creating and the way
to go through it is to trust in your
ideas
if you're concerned that that's too
egotistical like oh I'm so great I got
these great ideas great take yourself
out of the equation
trust that the idea came from somewhere
and it was given to you
and it's your responsibility to birth it
into life it's not even your idea it was
given to you
and then go off and create
one of the things that has really helped
me achieve speed and momentum is
I've learned to not judge the ideas that
come to me
I've just said you know what because I
came up with this idea now I have to go
do something about it and sometimes it
turns into the next great thing and
sometimes it goes nowhere that's okay
right the first top 10 video I ever made
on my channel was on Kanye West and he's
behind me on the wall there he is Kanye
West
because my friend
made a blog post about Kanye uh that was
in a negative light and so I wanted to
make it positive say Hey you can learn
from him and so I made a top 10 video on
Kanye West just to show my friend I had
other things planned today shut that all
down just to make this one video just to
show my friend with no plan of this is
gonna be my next big idea right people
say well how did you know I didn't know
I got an idea and I did something about
it
I'm not that smart to be able to project
10 years forward and say Here's Where
the world is going right maybe I can
leave that to Elon Musk I'm not that
smart
but it came to me so I did it and it
turned into something amazing
I've had other ideas that that I started
and didn't go anywhere either the idea
wasn't good enough or or more likely my
energy just kind of faded from it and so
I stopped doing it but at least I gave
it a shot all of these ideas that you've
got you don't know which one's going to
work out they could all be practically
speaking great ideas what's the best
idea for you I don't know you don't know
either until you start to try it
by taking the immediate action on it
you have to trust in your ideas that
they came to you for a reason are you
supposed to do something about them
so how do we start doing how do you
start taking the action how do you start
getting getting St unstuck in your head
of all the stuff that holds us back from
actually creating let me give some Steps
step number one
idea to action
take your brain out of the equation
there's a phrase that when when you're
in your head you're dead like as soon as
you start overthinking something it's
over
you came up with the idea you're gonna
do something about it when today
you came with the idea so you're gonna
do something about it when right now
what's your next idea what are you
thinking of right to go do something
about it immediate action take the
because you came up with the idea
therefore you must go do the thing
that's the training you want to give
yourself doesn't mean you have to go and
do some big thing but you have to get
started immediate momentum you want to
start a YouTube channel great you pull
out your phone and you make a video it
doesn't matter what you say it doesn't
matter what the lighting is don't worry
about the sound don't worry about having
a fancy microphone or fancy camera you
pull out your phone you press record and
you say you're starting the channel and
you post that first video
okay but then it's gonna suck great
which Lisa Point number two expect to
suck at the beginning
why do you expect to be great out of the
gate you will not be great out of the
gate doesn't mean that you suck as a
human just means that your product sucks
but it's your first attempt that's okay
when you try anything you fall when you
get on a bicycle you didn't just ride
right you get a skateboard you didn't
just go
you're gonna suck that's okay that's the
learning process you're gonna learn a
lot more and get better a lot quicker by
actually trying where we're stuck in
learning and researching and planning
and then nothing ends up getting created
you are wasting your best energy on
planning this is what most this is what
most people do this is what happens
almost all the time you can with an idea
you think it's a great idea
oh my gosh it's such a great idea
great you spend the next
day or until you go to sleep planning
researching preparing
and then you wake up tomorrow and say I
can't do that that's crazy that idea I
had yesterday is crazy I can't do that
who did I think I was to be able to do
that you spent your best energy your
most confident energy your most bold
energy on doing the wrong thing planning
instead of making planning is important
but it's not the first thing you should
do the first thing you do is take some
kind of action some kind of immediate
momentum some kind of commitment
especially to somebody else that you're
going to do something
so if you want to start a YouTube
channel you take out your phone and say
hi I'm going to start my YouTube channel
I don't know what I'm going to make
content of I'm really nervous but I've
been putting this off for five years and
I'm tired of putting things off so I
don't know join my journey and let's see
how it goes great post
and as you start making
you're gonna get better at it your first
thing is supposed to suck if you're
going to get started you're going to
start making YouTube videos as an
example and your first video is amazing
then you actually suck then you waited
too long your first version of whatever
you do should be terrible that's okay
so Step One is listen to the ideas trust
the ideas they are right for you because
they came to you you got to do something
about it take immediate action
and in Step number two is expect to suck
reduce the burden of expectation on
yourself that you have to be great from
the start as kids we do this right we
start we try we fail we laugh hahaha and
as adults all of a sudden we're afraid
to do anything
and what you do is just slide into more
of your comfort zone and more your
comfort zone more of your comfort zone
more of your comfort zone and then
realize why do I hate my life so much
because you're doing the same thing
every day because you're afraid to
Branch out a little bit
just expect to suck
reduce that burden that you have to be
amazing
and if you keep practicing you keep
loving it you keep building it guess
what you're gonna get great at it
doesn't have to take a decade this hacks
his shortcuts model success you'll get
there faster
but you still have to do the journey
and step one of the journey is the most
important step and is also the most
painful step that it's gonna suck
amazing every time you suck at something
at the start pat yourself on the back
you did a good job
step number three
and this is just the caveat is pay
attention to your energy when you come
up with ideas okay I'm assuming you're
in a positive bold ambitious confident
courageous State when you are feeling a
positive emotion the ideas that flow
through you are the right ideas for you
however when you're feeling negative low
you're feeling judgmental you're feeling
anger you're feeling depression you're
feeling rage you're you're upset that
somebody else is having success when
you're in a negative mindset
the ideas that come to you are not the
one ones for you those are the ones to
sit on right like I'm gonna show her I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this thing to him I'm
gonna I'm gonna get my Revenge by doing
that okay let those are the ideas to sit
on and it's funny because those are the
ideas we usually act on
the spontaneous ideas that come to you
that are negative you're more likely to
act on than the spontaneous ones that
come to you that are positive
you're more likely to send that nasty
text or leave that negative review or do
that negative thing instead of the
positive one and so if you're in a
negative state of mind that's when it's
worth waiting till tomorrow you know if
tomorrow you think it's the right call
okay then then let's think about it but
not in the moment don't do the negative
ones in the moment but if it's positive
if you just came back from a seminar or
you're watching this video or you're
around amazing humans and you get these
great ideas those are the ones that you
need to take some immediate action on
you have amazing ideas
you have a a heart and a soul that wants
a serve that wants to help that wants to
contribute that wants to not just fill
your pockets and fill your bank account
but also contribute and help other
people you know you've got something
much bigger inside you
but it does not come out
unless you start to listen to those
ideas and start to do something about
them
so the next time an idea comes to you
maybe you got one right now
maybe something's flowing through you
right now
learn to trust that idea tell yourself
that great ideas flow through you
that you need to take some immediate
action on it and that it's gonna suck at
the beginning and that's the best and
that's how you learn because if you kept
doing that do that for three months do
that for six months do that for 12
months the amount of amazing things
you're gonna help create for yourself
for your family for your community for
the world
is going to be just outstanding and I
can't wait to see what you end up making
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five practice your
beliefs you are what you consistently do
it's not what you do some of the times
it's not what you do when you feel
motivated or you had enough sleep or
that it's the perfect conditions out
there you are where you consistently do
the one-off moments don't mean anything
you can have a chocolate bar but if the
rest of your days are eaten healthy all
the time guess what you're not going to
gain a ton of weight and likewise the
other way around if you have a life that
you're not following through on any of
your goals and then you have one great
moment or one great day guess what you
fall back down
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
struggle because you have these moments
where you feel alive empowered on top of
the world amazing and you might even put
a little bit of that into practice but
if it's not consistent
then it never happens and it's almost
better to not even know what you're
capable of this is the part of the curse
of being an entrepreneur is you know
you're capable of great things you see
an amazing future amazing world of what
you could build
but then you also see your lack of
follow-through and the lack of delivery
and the lack of execution and it's that
constant grind against your self-worth
to say I should be doing more but I'm
not it's almost better to have no goals
and have no dreams and I have no
ambition because then you're good then
you're in in Bliss because you're
ignorant of what's what you're capable
of
so how do you fix it I look at myself
and anytime I want to make a change in
my life it goes to the schedule
my schedule has to map to my ambitions
right your schedule needs to map to your
Ambitions what you say you wanted a life
needs to be in your life right hope is
not is not enough hoping that you have
enough inspiration hoping that you get
motivated hoping that you'll be ready
one day that's not enough it's not a day
of the week right someday is not it's
not a day of the week Sunday is but
someday is not a day of the week and so
whatever you wanted a life has to be in
your calendar whatever success looks
like for you how finances relationships
whatever it looks like for you whatever
that perfect vision is in your head
whatever you have on your dream board of
what you want to accomplish in your life
okay great how do you accomplish that
how do you get there it's your habits
success is habits success equals habits
where are your habits in your calendar
so what are you doing
when you wake up in the morning what are
you doing every single day of the week
what are you doing for planning for your
for you know the the quarter and the
week and the even the year ahead what
are you doing what are you doing to
change what's in your calendar to make
sure that if you actually did those
things like if you look at your week
look at your next week
look at what's in your calendar
your health goals your your relationship
goals not just the goals but the
execution against it you can say you
want to have a great body or you want to
get healthy this year great what does
that look like where in your calendar
are you spending time planning your food
and working out and taking care of
yourself it has to be a time not just
not just a blank space this is the
problem we'll book a lot of our business
stuff but not our personal stuff I book
all my personal stuff my time with Nina
is in my calendar the time to celebrate
with the kids and families in the
calendar it's in the calendar it's as
important as a business meeting because
what happens is when you have blank
spots in your calendar
you start living an unintentional life
right when you set up a calendar and you
create the blocks of time for where
you're going to spend when you're going
to wake up and what you're going to work
on and when you're going to take care of
your body and when you're going to take
care of your relationships or take care
of self
right if when that's in your calendar
that's living an intentional life
when you just have a bunch of blank
spots
you get distracted pull up your phone
and dive into Instagram and three hours
later you're still on it and you feel
worse about yourself so it's about
creating an intentional life for
yourself and that starts with your
calendar you are what you consistently
do you are what you repeatedly do so how
do we do it how are some of the steps
what what are the three action items for
you well step one is to figure out what
do you want
especially on a belief scale like what
do you want to believe
what is the difference between where you
are now and where you want to go and
this can be hard for Achievers because
you probably
are the most ambitious person that you
know right you're the one who's caring
about other people you're the one
encouraging other people but nobody's
doing it for you so what are the beliefs
that you need to have what's the most
important belief change that you need to
have that you're not getting from your
immediate circle doesn't mean you stop
pointing to other people keep doing
that's amazing you're built to serve
it's going to fill you up but you need
something to pour into you otherwise you
don't grow
right if you're just feeding other
people and nothing's feeding you you
don't grow you're just gonna get drained
so what's going to be feeding into you
the belief
that would make the difference between
where you are right now and where you
want to be what is that single belief
great so getting clear on what that one
don't don't worry about having a hundred
different beliefs yet tackle one thing
at a time what's the single most
important belief that you need to have
for yourself to get your next level of
growth great step number two
who is doing that right now
who was doing that and creating an
environment and habits around it so for
me I want to believe in myself more I
want to spread more belief to other
people as well so what's in my
environment well my physical environment
you can see here from me wearing this
outfit to having you know the pictures
behind me on the wall these people all
inspire me for different reasons to the
videos that I make and consume to the
work that I do in my community to the
new Discord that I set up Evan
carmichael.biz if you want to come and
join us uh that's part of what I do
every day to make me feel like I believe
in myself more believe in in me as a
human believe in the work that I'm doing
believe that it will work out I want
more belief and I've designed habits and
rituals to help me get it where most
people again do not wake up and feel
like today is going to be an amazing day
and they're just bursting full of energy
and on top of the world from the moment
they wake up no I woke up this morning
it was just past seven
um I don't sleep to an alarm so I woke
up and just I wake up when my body tells
me to wake up so I woke up just past
seven
um I didn't know what day it was you
know I'm tired I wake up I go to the
bathroom and on my way I put on an oldie
song and and all these music gets me
moving gets me bouncing gets me jiving
and then immediately start going to
community stuff right I'm in the
bathroom I'm listening to my oldies I
look at my intention for the day today
I'm recording YouTube videos how do I
want to show up what I want to do who do
I want to be showing up on the content
and then go to community
and I go I joined my Discord and I'm
giving love to people because it makes
me feel like what I do matters and it
makes me feel more belief right I've got
videos on that you know remind me of who
I want to be I'm around my heroes and
mentors but deciding
the difference that you need to believe
between now and where you're going and
then two putting it into your calendar
especially the morning routine of how
you're going to show up so it's not an
accident so that you don't hope that
that you show up and you do it today but
that it's it's marked in your calendar
and then step three and this is the
hardest for a lot of people is you do
what's in your calendar here's a really
important rule that if you do this it
will change your life
when you are deciding
what to do in your calendar on the day
of
you cannot change what's in today's
calendar you can change tomorrows but
you can't change today here's what I
mean if you're looking at your calendar
and you set out your goals right here
here's who I want to be this week here's
what I want to get done this week I want
to wake up at this time and I want to
work out and I want to connect with my
family and I want to serve and whatever
whatever the chunks of time are for you
there's a tendency to in the moment
change
where on Sunday you look at your
calendar and said here's what I'm going
to do this is going to be an exciting
week it's great but then come Thursday
morning you don't want to wake up at
that time or you see what's in the
calendar I don't want to go for that run
I don't want to make those calls I don't
want to make those videos and then you
don't and you quickly fall off track
sound familiar is it making sense it
looks so great on the weekend when you
plan this but now when you're actually
doing it you don't do it
and then what happens is the next time
you say you're going to do something you
don't believe yourself because you let
yourself off the hook too easily so the
rule becomes
you can only change tomorrow's calendar
not today you're tired
you had a rough day
you don't think this workout's working
for you anymore you don't think making
videos is aligned with you anymore great
tomorrow you don't have to do it
tomorrow you can change but today you're
doing it because you said you were going
to do it tomorrow you can sleep in
because today you had a last night you
had a rough night so today you're extra
tired but you're still getting up when
you said you were going to get up and
you still do the things that are in your
calendar and then tomorrow you can sleep
in and tomorrow you can adjust
the workout the business plan whatever
if it doesn't feel right anymore but not
today don't trust yourself in the moment
because your brain is going to tell you
to play small your brain is going to
remind you why you can't do these things
your brain is going to find a reason for
you to let yourself off the hook again
like it did last time
you know what you want
so what you said you were going to do on
the weekend when you look at your
calendar you have to show up the day of
so you have to get really clear on the
belief that you want to have that will
make the difference for you you need to
surround yourself with those Heroes and
role models and change your morning
routine to reflect it and then you need
to actually do what's in your calendar
and if something's off or it doesn't
work you change it for tomorrow but you
can't change it in the moment you are
what you consistently do
you know you've got so much inside you
and so much that you want to share and
serve and help
and you keep letting yourself down
and it's it's time to change it
you're ready to change it
you're ready to move past it you're
ready to be the person who follows
through you're ready to be the person
who with that big dream starts to make
momentum towards it
the only difference is being the person
who does what you consistently say you
will do rule number six focus on
customer Obsession when you figure out
what you stand for everything becomes so
much easier
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs who
they're doing this and they're doing
that and they're doing this and then
also this thing and it's
feels like it's all over the place right
have you ever felt that you're doing so
many things and it feels like it's all
over the place and you don't know how to
bring it together it doesn't feel like
it fits together nobody understands what
you're doing either
the way to bring it together
is to figure out your most important
core value
if you actually did the exercise and
I've talked about this in in both my
books built to serve your one word
if you actually did the exercise you
think about what do I stand for if you
have to pick something right now your
single most important core value what
would you pick mine is believe what's
yours as all sorts of exercise we get
into on how to actually do it if you're
struggling with that but just pick pick
something it's not going to be so far
off whatever comes to mind right now
pick that
now look at everything that you're
creating that you're selling that you're
offering that's in your mind
and they all now kind of make sense
everything that I do
is believe whether it's making videos
like this whether it's
uh making my nft projects with this
going on my Discord whether it's my
other social media content strategies
whether it's speaking whether it's books
whether it's my entrepreneur Heroes
trading cards that we turn entrepreneurs
into into Heroes and made them made them
their own baseball cards and use that to
raise six figures for Kiva to help
entrepreneurs in Africa build their
businesses right whatever I'm doing it
feels like it could be all over the
place but it's not because it's still
belief because at the end of the day
what I want to do is spread belief
Jeff Bezos wants to spread customer
obsession
he wants to he wants to make a better
experience for customers and so he's in
all sorts of different fields
why it feels like it's all over the
place it's not because Amazon is not
just a book business
Amazon is in the customer experience
business
that's his most important core value
what's your most important core value
it'll help make everything make more
sense it'll help make your life make
more sense your business makes more
sense and it'll help your customers
understand better what you're doing I
remember watching a clip of Jay-Z being
interviewed and
they were asking him how do you move
from
making music to being an entrepreneur to
having all these businesses how does
that make sense
and he said it's just an extension of
being creative
see for him it's not just about the
music it's about expressing creativity
and every field can add more creativity
entrepreneurship can be more creative
investing can be more creative product
lines can be more creative he sees
himself not as a musician but as a force
of creativity his most important core
value is creativity so it just makes
sense to him to be able to jump from one
field to another to another to another
where most people are stuck in the craft
right you don't just do one thing you
don't want to do one thing that's why
you're an entrepreneur you don't want to
just do one little narrow thing for the
rest of your life
but it feels like you're all over the
place
and you are until you can wrap it under
your most important core value and what
that does is gives you permission to
explore and to try and to Taste and to
go into new fields
but also
the ability to do something much bigger
because whatever your most important
core value is that's what you want to
spread to the world
I want to spread more belief to the
world Jay-Z wants to spread more
creativity to the world and he could
have done what most people do
most rappers most musicians stick to
just doing that thing okay well that's
what I love and that's what I know and
so I'm just gonna stick to doing that
how you become Mogul status
right how you start to change the rules
of the game how you start to have a much
wider impact and bigger reach is to
recognize that I don't just do one thing
I don't just have one skill
I've got a message
I've got a core value on it put out to
the world
and there's multiple ways for me able to
do that
so Jay-Z sees himself through the lens
of creativity and then it makes sense
and it gives himself the permission to
go off and Chase those other ambitions
so for you think about what is that most
important core value in some easy hacks
again both my books go through this in a
lot more detail but think about who your
favorite teacher was growing up think
about who what you loved about your
parents think about your favorite movies
your favorite songs uh think about
anything that made you come alive any
experience why did you love that teacher
for me it was my my OAC my grade 12 uh
French teacher why it's not because she
taught me French
your favorite teacher wasn't because
they taught you a subject matter because
they made you a better human Madame Farr
at my school she helped me believe in
myself more
when I doubted myself when I wasn't
getting the grades that I wanted to get
she helped turn me from a BNC student to
a straight A Plus student in my last
year
she believed in me and she taught me how
to believe in myself that's why I love
her not because she taught me French
right who was your favorite teacher why
why they made you a better human somehow
what was it about them and when you can
connect the dots and all the things that
make you come alive from your favorite
teacher and favorite books and favorite
music favorite lyrics favorite favorite
TV shows favorite movies favorite
friends right favorite Heroes you can
connect the dots you like them but
instead of it it being a happenstance
like you hope that good things happen to
you you can now design it you can
engineer it
I want to bring more believe into my
life and now that that's on my
Consciousness now that I'm aware of it I
can make that happen as opposed to just
hoping something positive happens to me
when you figure out your one word your
most important core value you can
engineer your life to bring more of that
into you and then the more you have you
can give more you can serve more you can
help more you can uplift up others more
you can motivate and Inspire and give
courage and Hope
to the world more
because you have more to give right
review if you're running on empty you
don't have much to give to anybody
so it starts with that awareness
of what is your single most important
core value
and then bring that to your life
and your business
I believe Bezos is about customer
experience
Jay-Z is about creativity what are you
what are you
what do you value the most
and then with that lens look at your
life
look at your business and see where are
you following through
and crushing it and where are you not
living up to it where are you doing the
wrong things
whatever your life needs a little bit
more of that
because when you can look at your life
through that lens that's your best self
looking back at you
that's the life you want to be living
your highest self looking back at you
and saying hey right here
the reason why you're not happy
is because you're not living your most
important core value
figure that out and you have a road map
you have a guide you have a compass
for the rest of your life rule number
seven keep going my philosophy on losing
is you either win or you learn you win
you got your goal hey hey
congratulations pat yourself on the back
or you learn you learned how not to do
it again hopefully you've improved and
you've gotten better it's only a loss if
you quit it's only a loss if you never
get back up it's only a loss if you stop
trying
somebody asked me on my Instagram
yesterday I love this business that I'm
doing but it's just not working out what
do I do
and my answer is hey if you still love
it you have to keep going
you have to keep trying you have to keep
getting up you have to keep not just
doing the same thing you've been doing
you have to keep looking exploring
trying new ways you have to have to have
to have to keep going because if you
stop now if you love the thing and you
stop now you will regret that decision
for the rest of your life
how many times have you quit on
something that you love then you look
back you say I wish I what if I just
kept going what if I just tried one more
day what if I just tried one more week
what if I just kept going because I
would have been in a different spot
and now I regret not trying
if you don't love it great quit I mean I
think people stain things for too long
as well people stay in businesses for
too long people saying relationships are
too long out of fear out of insecurity
the love was gone a long time ago and
you should have left a long time ago but
you're too afraid to do it that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
what you love doing and it hasn't worked
out yet you have to keep going
when I
was in my first business that this is
the thing that really helped me I was 19
years old I wanted to quit on my
business I was struggling I was making
no money 300 bucks a month I own 30 of a
company that was not making any money
and I was working every day and I just
had enough I had enough I was fed up
like how much further can I go how much
longer can I go and just not see money
and not see results and I felt like I
was a pretty happy optimistic positive
guy but it just every day it just beat
me down a little bit more a little bit
more a little bit more and I was too
embarrassed and ashamed to tell people
so it's all by myself and I quit on my
business partner it was the worst day of
my life
and the thing that kept me going
was the fear of regret
that this is not a loss unless I quit
this is not really a loss unless I
actually throw in the towel and go do
something else because I still wanted it
to work in my heart of hearts I still
love this thing I wanted to do something
with it it just I was quitting because I
wasn't getting the results yet
and what I told myself from 19 almost 20
was when when I'm an old man at 40
you know I'm 40 how old am I now I'm 41
right now so it's funny thinking about
it but when I'm an old man at 40 and my
life is over and and I hate my life and
that's it and I'm falling apart
I will regret this I will regret that I
quit
and that feeling
gave me the courage
to go one more day to say I I can't quit
yet this is not I have not given it
everything that I've got I have not left
it all out on the field right there's
still more in me to give to serve the
help there's more effort
but what it did was
forced me to start to think differently
because I couldn't keep going the way I
was going because what I was doing
obviously was not working every idea
that I tried was not working I needed to
think of something radically different
and that's where the idea of modeling
success came in for me it was finally
out of desperation not out of
inspiration not out of mentorship not
anything else not as genius wasn't that
smart it was out of desperation that I
asked myself who else has built a
software company before I cannot be the
first guy to have tried to do this
there's no way somebody has figured this
out like who's done this
and by modeling Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft that started the path
for my company to start to have success
in a short amount of time I closed my
first deal it was 13 and a half thousand
dollars I felt like I was rich on top of
the world and it gave me momentum it
gave me hope and it also gave me a
strategy that I could keep using
so if you have lost recently
there's two key ways that you need to
get out of it
okay the first is emotional
and then the second is strategy logical
that the emotional part is you feel hurt
you feel
scared you feel hopeless you feel
insecure you feel like it it this will
never work it may never work all these
people may be relying on you hopefully
nobody saw you fail we're just afraid of
this judgment and disappointing people
feel like you're not valuable
feel like you're wasting your time
and so the way to get through the
emotional pain
is one to focus on regret
that if you love this thing
and you quit now you will regret this
whether it's 10 years in the future 20
years in the future 30s in the future
you don't want to think back like I had
that shot back then I had that shot and
I didn't take it and I quit too soon
like don't let that be you
fear of regret and the second is service
that you're not doing this just for you
that there's people who are struggling
and they need your help they need your
support there's people who will be
counted on you that your story can
Inspire other people as well
and so sometimes you need the the hug
which is service and sometimes you need
to push which is regret
depending on where you're at what you're
feeling but when you lose
there are lots of logical strategic
practical ways to get out but if you
don't solve the emotional issue first
you'll stay stuck
so it's the emotional issue you have to
deal with first
that just because you lost doesn't mean
that you are a loser as a human right
just because your business hasn't worked
out yet doesn't mean that you as a
person have no self-worth your business
might not have any worth yet but it
doesn't mean that you have no worth and
that's that's something that took me a
long time to be able to separate out
that you are not your business
you are amazing you are gifted you are
talented you are loved you want to
contribute you want to serve and then
you bring that to your business not that
you are your business
once you solve the the emotional side
then you can work through the Practical
side then you can think about okay how
do I how do I solve this problem how do
I break out of this rut that I'm facing
and one of my favorite ways now is
modeling success right find the person
who's done the thing that's why I make
so many videos that's why I profile so
many different entrepreneurs and
athletes and coaches and experts because
maybe the way Oprah Winfrey says it or
Tim Grover says it or Steve Jobs says it
or whoever maybe the way they say it
finally starts to land finally starts to
seep in to give you the idea that you
need to then explode your business
forward
first start with the emotional side and
solve that
that you are here to serve you are
valuable and that you will regret
quitting on this thing if you quit too
soon and then you can move the tactics
and strategies just like I did with my
business
I quit I quit on my partner
and said I'm done I need to feel
valuable as a human
and realize the next day I leaned in
more on the regret I do not want to live
with regret and being old men at 40 and
look back and say this was my moment
and then that led to the strategy the
Practical side to say okay but I can't
keep going how I'm going how do I solve
this problem okay modeling success
it's only a loss if you quit
it's only a loss if you stay down
it's only a loss if you tell yourself
that you suck and that will it will
never work out
you either win or you learn
the choice is yours
the get back up to learn the lessons
that you learned and to take another
shot because your goals matter because
your dreams matter because the thing
you've got inside your heart right here
can have a huge impact on the world and
we need to get the message out rule
number eight max out your Humanity your
purpose comes from your pain the thing
that you struggle the most with as a
human being is what you want to help
other people through for the rest of
your life something terrible happened to
you you know at some point in our lives
something terrible happened to me
happened to you nobody gets through this
life trauma free something terrible
happened to you and that terrible thing
will Define you in one of two ways
either that was negative and in that
story haunts you and holds you back and
and fills you with all these limited
beliefs or
you recognize that that thing that
happened to you is The Ultimate Gift in
that your purpose now becomes to help
other people not struggle the same way
that you did when you can transform that
giant pain that you had emotional pain
when you felt the most worthless as a
human being into something powerful and
positive because it's now not just about
you anymore it's about serving and
helping others who are like you
that's when everything changes my
purpose is to help entrepreneurs believe
in themselves more because the the worst
day of my life the worst moments in my
life for when I was in my first business
and I quit on my business partner and I
I had no belief I
I was down on myself I felt worthless I
felt I was working every day and just
nothing was working out and what do I do
what do I do and I I quit I'm my
business partner I quit because it was
just too much too much work too much
stress too much negative thoughts too
much just lack of self-worth not enough
belief
and I woke up the next day and I and I
still I went back to work because I did
not want to live with the regret and I
actually had a voice of Oprah in my head
telling me just find a different way to
stand
if it's not working out it's okay don't
quit just find a different way to stand
and I eventually made it through
we we built the company sold it I had
other successes but
the thing that fills me up forever is
helping other entrepreneurs who are
trying to believe in themselves because
that's back to who I was
and I still make the content for 19 year
old Evan because there are millions of
people out there right now who currently
are 19 year old Evan
and so
one of the most helpful things you can
do
is try to figure out a couple things one
what was that most painful moment like
how do we turn this into
practical a lot of entrepreneurs a lot
of you watching this channel you are
positive you are energetic you are
enthusiastic you are pouring into other
people you're probably the most
optimistic person most dream filled
person in your circle and that's amazing
and that's a gift and you should keep
doing that and
you still have lots of moments where you
don't believe in yourself or you don't
have the courage that you need you don't
have the boldness that you need and and
we don't like looking backwards you
don't like look into the painful moments
the entrepreneurs ambitious positive
people it's like I don't want to think
about all the negative things that
happen to me I want to go off and build
this thing I want to say stocking
negativity is that you can you relate
but it's important to think about that
most painful moment not to sit there and
live there and say oh woe is me but to
recognize
that there are millions of people right
now who currently are still struggling
with that thing that thing that you have
overcome even if you're not done growing
learning improving yet that thing that
you struggled with that you're coming
through many many many many many many
millions of people right now today are
struggling with that thing
and they need you they need your hope
they need your voice they need your
message you need your inspiration you
can reach those people in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't that Oprah Winfrey
can't that other people can't because
you experienced it
and I I and Oprah have it
so step number one is to think about
what is that most painful moment
that you struggled through
that you wouldn't wish on anybody else
step number two then becomes well how
did you get out of it again you're not
done climbing but you're way better off
than you used to be it's funny how we
we criticize ourselves for not being
further ahead like I I should be up here
her followed that idea I'd be over here
by now all these other people are doing
all these amazing things and I'm still
feeling like I'm stuck okay
but also look at how far you've come
right you know you want to keep climbing
growing swimming Etc but you've come a
long way compared to who you used to be
and every now and then we need to pause
reflect Pat ourselves on the shoulders
say you know what I'm I'm way further
ahead Than I Used to Be
do you from five years ago or ten years
ago would look at the you today and say
holy cow I can't believe you've done
that
right Evan from 10 years ago who had I
don't know a thousand subscribers on his
YouTube channel would look to Evan now
and say oh my gosh that's crazy I can't
believe you did that even though right
now I'm thinking I gotta do more I got
to be better I gotta work harder gotta
gotta go faster gotta come with new
ideas I'm not pushing enough right if
you look back man there's been some
tremendous growth you've grown a lot
and so how did you how did you get out
of the hole that you were in how did you
stop struggling as much you probably
tried a million different things but
there's one or two or three things that
worked that's teachable
to other people the thing that saved me
was modeling success
I looked at Bill Gates's story and I
modeled that for myself and my software
company then started to have success so
what have I taught for the past 20 plus
years now is how can other people model
success so how did you get out of the
hole that you were in
and then how can you then teach that to
other people
because they're struggling because all
of the tests and tries and attempts and
failures that you went through to find
the one two three things at work you can
Now shortcut somebody else's path
this is what I think it means to max out
your Humanity this is what I what I
think it means to live in what Jonathan
Fields calls maximum sustainable
generosity it's like how can you keep
giving in a sustainable way
that fills you up because you don't want
to just do things for you humans are
built to serve it's wired inside you you
want to feel like you matter like today
matters like the work you're going to do
today is going to be meaningful to
somebody
and the people you love help the most
are the ones who are currently
struggling with the thing that you
struggled with
so figure out what that thing is that
most painful moment in your life that
you never want to go back to
and then how did you get out of the hole
now that is teachable
and then step number three is Having the
courage to share your story
I get it it's scary it's difficult it's
hard to put yourself out there to share
what you went through the struggles you
may be afraid of how you're going to be
judged or seen you know today you were
just a normal person and now tomorrow
you're gonna put this out there now now
maybe you're you're scarred or you're
tarnished
but it's important because
by you staying silent it perpetuates the
Silence by you being afraid to share
your story everybody else who's
struggling with the same thing that
you're struggling with they feel afraid
too they feel like they don't belong
they feel like they're weird and not
accepted and not normal
by you putting out your story and what
you went through and are still going
through
it gives the permission to other people
to feel like they have somewhere that
they belong that they are normal that
they're going to be okay too that
they're not alone
so you share in your story I used to
really struggle with thinking well only
egotistical Maniacs share their story
and talk about themselves right it's
about serving well hold on
by you sharing your story is actually
serving you're not sharing your story
just to have the spotlight on you just
to say how amazing you are you're
sharing your story because you're hoping
that other people can see themselves in
you because your purpose comes from your
pain you're trying to reach the people
who currently are who you used to be
and in looking at you and hearing you
what you've come through and where you
are now that will serve as inspiration
for them to keep going
or for them to even get started or for
them to not take their life today
because they saw your video or they read
your book or they saw the post you put
on social media
sharing your story is not about you
sharing your stories about impacting
others and they can see themselves in
you where they can't see themselves in
Evan Carmichael or Oprah Winfrey or
insert you know whatever expert Guru or
entrepreneur
you have to figure out what that most
painful moment in your life was
you have to understand how you got out
of the hole because it's teachable and
then you have to share your story
and put the message out there
because your story will change
somebody's life ultimately your purpose
comes from your pain
you want to serve you want to help you
want to feel like today matters you want
to feel like when you show up to do the
thing that you're gonna do today it's
gonna have an impact maybe not on
millions of people's lives but on at
least one person's life if you felt like
today you are going to touch in a deeply
meaningful profound way at least one
person's life
you're going to show up totally
differently than if you felt like today
doesn't matter then nobody cares
and just forget about the day
I love you I want to see you win let's
make it happen rule number nine secure
your financial future most people sleep
walk through life because they don't
love what they're doing you wake up and
you don't love what you're doing you
feel like it doesn't matter or you feel
like nobody will care if you show up or
you don't and if if that was your day
if you today felt like you know what it
doesn't matter I show up I don't show up
I make I don't make nobody's gonna
really care if that was not just today
but tomorrow the next day the next day
the next day if that was every day of
your life how sad would your life be
this is why we have so much anxiety and
depression and suicide is because people
feel like they don't matter and we want
to matter to others it's wired into us
we want to feel like we are important we
want to feel like what we're going to do
today is going to create some kind of
meaning and impact on somebody else's
life we are built to serve you want to
help it's not enough to want to do
something just for yourself you want to
feel like you matter to somebody else
today
most people sleepwalk through their
lives
never feeling like they meant anything
to anybody especially in their work
and it's why a lot of people default to
entrepreneurship to try to say well
here's my chance to be to be My Own Boss
use my chance to live my own life here's
my chance to do something that matters
without just being some Cog in a
corporate machine
but unless you connect the work that
you're doing to serving and helping
other people you still won't feel great
when I first started in my business it
was really really hard
um
both businesses but the business where I
help Inspire entrepreneurs and I got
asked to speak and I remember just
loving the speaking part and at the time
I was doing a speaking gig a month or so
and just wasn't getting enough feedback
I'd go and it'd be amazing I'd be
certain so nervous and so scared to get
up on stage
but then the end would be so amazing and
to see that you helped somebody you know
how good it feels to help somebody
you know how good it feels to make
somebody smile or laugh or cry or
for them just to say thank you
you know you know you know how good it
feels when somebody says thank you for
what you've done for me today
that is more valuable than whatever
they're paying you for your product or
service right we all want that that's
the good thing to get addicted to so
when I first started speaking and
helping
I I was getting that once a month and
doing a speaking gig but then I wasn't
feeling it throughout the month this is
the hard part of being an entrepreneur
especially at the beginning when you
don't have enough feedback you're not
feeling valuable it takes too long to
get your product to service or service
to Market to see the at the action that
your customers are getting from it
and so I had to remind myself of what I
was doing I had to remind myself I made
a PowerPoint file where I looked at my
comments every day the feedback that I
was getting even though it was for three
weeks ago I still looked at the feedback
again to remind myself of what I was
doing was important
when I started my YouTube Channel I
didn't get any feedback I wasn't getting
any comments right my first video took a
year to get three comments and it was my
mom my older sister and then some random
guy so I wasn't getting a lot of
feedback
but I still would look at my comments
every day just to feel like hey this is
important like if I got one comment a
week I'd be so happy
yeah I see that person I help that
person
I got to keep going I got to keep making
got to keep creating and even to this
day it still is among the most important
things that I do
I'm I'm pretty in love with Discord
right now I created my own Discord
server you can join believe Nation it's
Evan carmichael.biz it's free and I'm in
there every morning right now
just helping and it's one of my
go-to's right now for how I start my day
start my day I look at my calendar I set
my attention for the day and then I'll
go to my Discord server and start
helping people
because
having a million views on a video or
however many subscribers or whatever it
does not feel as good as going into
Discord server and helping one person
believing themselves a little bit more
so you have to figure out a way to make
it
not a sleep walk every day
to make it feel like you're doing
something that matters that you matter
that today is going to matter that you
show up in a way that matters so let me
break down a couple things that I think
can help number one is the big picture
has to matter
this is why people struggle in jobs
because you feel like nobody cares right
this job doesn't mean anything
the company doesn't care if I'm here or
not even the company's Mission isn't
that important you don't feel connected
to what you're doing every day you have
to feel connected to the mission
if you're an entrepreneur it's a lot
easier but you have to be doing work
that you actually think matters a lot of
entrepreneurs start a company just
trying to make money you're just trying
to pay the bills you're just trying to
make some cash you're just trying to
look at the hot opportunity and if you
can't connect to the reason why you're
doing it the mission you won't win the
number one rule for success is you have
to love the thing that you're doing if
you're doing it just to make money
making money is important it is
important you have to do it it needs to
be in your top five but it can't be
number one what is number one
you have to design your business that
you feel like you're on a mission that
you're here to serve that you're doing
some kind of good that you you may not
be there yet you may not be
accomplishing anything close to it yet
but it's the goal it's the mission that
you're trying to go off and achieve
so number one is you have to feel like
on a big scale on a macro scale that if
it all plays out this is going to really
really really really really matter to
you but to other people as well
two is the micro wins have to be there
you know it's the it's the big why in
the little y so the first one is the Big
Y the big why what am I trying to
accomplish the second one is a little
wide little wise the daily little wins
you could be
inspired by your big why
it could be driving you it could be
feeling you but
there will be many days where the Big Y
is not enough
there'll be many days where you feel
like you can't do that big why that who
were you that think you could do that
crazy big thing that it's never going to
happen that you're not going to make it
that it's just it's just not worth it
there'll be many days when you feel like
that
especially when you don't see any
tractional momentum happening that's
what the little y's come into place the
little Y is the daily little feeling
like hey I did something to help one
person I may not be able to impact the
world today I may not be having a
life-changing product or service or
launch or video or whatever but I can
help one person today that's why I go to
the Discord every morning that's why I'm
in my comments every day because
my big why is to change the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I'm never going to do
it and there are days where that feels
way too big and too scary I channel that
into this like this video I want this
video to matter I'm sitting here in the
parking lot in my car while Nina's at a
a pet store getting stuff for the dogs
right I'm just talking to my cell phone
but I want this video to matter I want
this video to touch you I want this
video to have some kind of meaningful
impact that maybe this is the day the
way that I say the words the energy that
I show up with maybe maybe just maybe
this is a day that you finally go off
and make some kind of change maybe today
is the day that's my sincere hope
and
I need to still feel like
I'm touching somebody that talking to my
phone is not enough so going to the
Discord server talking to people
encouraging them giving them some love
just saying good morning just helping
people
it's crazy doing DMS in the morning on
my Instagram and spending eight seconds
making a video for somebody and then
seeing the reaction like you don't know
how much this video meant to me that you
would send this it's coming to me at the
right time today I really needed that
encouragement
took me eight seconds to do but it
changed somebody's life right is that
going to help me grow my subscribers or
comments or Revenue no right but it
feels really good
and you need those little y's so what
are the things that
are connected to your big mission
but are really small but it's a it's an
individual that you can help one person
that by you helping one person today
you've got your little why that can give
you the motivation to keep going
how do we stop sleepwalking through life
right Big Y you're on a big mission that
you're trying to accomplish something
huge step two is a little why we feel
like today is going to matter to
somebody to one human even if it doesn't
accomplish our big mission step number
three is to pay it forward
you know how good it feels to get a
comment to get a video to get a
personalized message for somebody to
help you out
Pay It Forward especially to small
creators my ask for you would be if you
if there's somebody that you follow
somebody who you who whose Journey
you're following along with maybe it's
your friend who's posting maybe it's
some total stranger who you've found
some of their content
go give them a little love
go get them a review on iTunes go give
them a comment on their YouTube or
Instagram or wherever you're following
them
it means so much
if it's a giant Channel
or someone's been doing it for a long
time you know I don't see all the
comments that come in don't don't leave
a comment on if you I mean leave a
comment on the videos but
it doesn't mean as much anymore as it
used to right because we get so many so
we're spoiled so the big the big
creators don't worry about it you can
it's always good karma that's to spread
positivity but if you had to pick
for the smaller ones
because just one person saying I see you
just one person saying thank you just
one person saying this message meant
something to me this just one just one
person
having that belief
is the difference quite often between
them quitting and them following through
your single message today to somebody
is going to be the difference I promise
you for somebody if you did that every
day it will for sure be the difference
for quite a number of people between
them quitting and then continuing on
because you took 15 seconds to send a
quick message to them
so Big Y little Y and then pay it
forward especially to the smart creators
we gotta get out of the Sleepwalk guys
we we want to feel like we matter we
want to feel like today matters we want
to feel like the work we do matters and
the best way that you can inspire people
you want to help the people around you
you want to help your community you want
to help your family you want to help the
people who might see you you want to
help people the best way to help them is
for you to stop sleepwalking is for you
to start doing things that matter it's
not for you to just
make a inspirational video
it's through your actions that if you
showed up today and decided that you're
going to remember your big why that
you're going to serve with your little
why that you're going to pay it forward
to other people
when you see the impact that that can
have on their life
it makes you reconnect to why you do
what you do
and if you woke up and did the thing
that made you remember why you do what
you do and you felt it not just words
you're telling yourself but you
genuinely felt it
holy cow look out because life starts to
get really really good and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is challenge yourself treat
yourself like you matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about think about how
you talk to other people you know think
about if you're watching this video if
you're a fan of this channel you are
probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even Tech even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror and you're just telling yourself
all the reasons why you can't do
something that voice inside your own
head sucks right tell yourself that you
can't make it that someone like you is
never going to do it we don't treat
ourselves with the same love of
compassion empathy that we have
for other people you wouldn't talk to
your worst enemy the way that you talk
to yourself and that's a big problem I
think that needs to shift that needs to
change because as long as you keep
talking to yourself
like you're a piece of garbage
then you're never going to accomplish
anything great
we have to start to shift it
I had a whole bunch of issues in how I
talk to myself
I used to say well I'm too shy I'm too
introvert I'm nobody's going to want to
hear my story my message doesn't matter
who am I to go off and do this I have to
have a huge ego even I'm sitting here
filming in a parking lot like I would I
would never do this only only people
with giant egos and
uh loud mouths would ever do that right
I'm still working to unwind all of that
but the more you can catch it and the
more you can shift it it allows you to
go off and do great things not just for
yourself but for other people because if
you fast forward
if the way you've been talking to
yourself for the past couple of years
continues to be the way that you talk to
yourself for the rest of your life
nothing changes
so how do we shift how do we get to a
point where hey we're actually saying
better things about ourselves number one
is you have to catch the voice you know
what is the negative voice what are you
saying to yourself because a lot of it
are just
it's not intentional
you know it's these automatic thoughts
it's a subconscious thoughts you come up
with an idea of what you can do and
immediately you shut yourself down
without even noticing it just it's a
default nature instantly boom no I can't
do that no you suck you can't do that
so what are the negative thoughts that
are coming up in your mind and just
trying to catch it
number two is whatever you want to have
more of you need to create that in your
life you need to create the habits and
routines to have more of it in your life
so for me I I want more belief right and
I go through this whole process of how
to figure out your most important core
value or your one word you can pick up
your one word or build the serve it'll
walk you through it
what do you need more of in your life I
need more belief and as much as I'm
trying to spread that to the world with
the videos and everything I make I also
need more of it myself I need more
belief for myself and so what helps me
believe in myself well I try to design a
life in an environment to help bring
that out more so
everything from the outfit that I wear
you know I tell myself I'm a superhero
going to work this is my believe uniform
just like Batman puts on his costume
from what my office looks like and the
pictures on my wall I've got my parents
on my wall and
looking at them reminds me of the
message that my mom would always give me
that I'm Advocate Shirley Carmichael I
could do anything and believe that I can
the videos that I make the the main
channel the top 10 Channel this Channel
all the content that I make is designed
to help me believe in myself more
that's what helps me come alive
um service you know thinking about
how what I'm gonna do will have an
impact on somebody else besides me
helps me have the courage to go off and
Chase down the goals that I have for
myself so what is it that makes you come
alive what do you need more of it in
your life because you're probably not
getting enough of it
right the thing that you need more in
your life you're not you're not getting
enough of it right now that's why that
negative voice is so powerful and
default
so think about the people who you're
hanging around and the media you're
consuming all of it you're not getting
enough of the thing that you need so how
do you get more of that thing and
engineering design it so that it's part
of your daily calendar that's not
randomly happening in your life but it's
with intent
must happen every day
so number one is catching that horse
what is that voice
number two is designing that environment
and the habits and the routines for
yourself so that you're around it
constantly you're changing our
environment to be around the thing that
you know that you want to be
and then number three is
Empower people to pull you out of the
Matrix you know Empower people to call
you out Empower people to give you
feedback
some of my favorite ways to do it
whenever I'm going to an event or
whatever I'm talking to somebody I
respect and I need some help input
guidance feedback I'll say tell me why I
suck remember I suck at this thing why
do I suck at this like how do I get
better
and when I do that it's because they
give me their honest feedback you know
when when you just ask for feedback
people will be afraid of hurting your
feelings and you won't get the full info
so I say tell me why I suck and they say
well you don't suck but
here's what you need to fix
I empower the people around me that if I
say scary difficult or hard
then I have to go up and do the thing
just because I said scary difficult to
hard I don't want to be the person who
plays small so my son particularly loves
this one right it's like Dad you did it
you said scary oh shoot okay now I have
to go off and do it what are your
trigger words what are the things that
make you stay small and then empower the
people around you to call you out on it
so that
when you don't catch it because you
won't catch it most of the time you
won't catch it but when you can't catch
it and somebody else can
not being defensive and not uh
putting our guard up and realizing that
hey this behavior is keeping me stuck
empowering the people around you to give
you the feedback to pull you out of the
Matrix so you can start turning what
subconscious to conscious
if you feel like
you're a little bit stuck
you know you want to do more and you're
capable of more and you want to serve
more and help more
and you know that you've got this voice
inside you that's keeping you there and
you're struggling with how do I get it
from subconscious and automatic negative
to subconscious and automatic positive
everything starts to change
you have to treat yourself like you
matter
just imagine that you were actually your
own best friend
just imagine that you came to you with
the problems that you're facing what
would you tell yourself
it's probably going to be something
loving something encouraging something
powerful something positive not the
words that you're actually using to talk
to yourself
this doesn't change in a day you know it
doesn't change in an instant
it's a process
but if every day
by day you can slowly start to believe
in yourself more Empower yourself more
talk to yourself in a better way
you're going to create
a much better life for yourself and then
you can pay it forward and help others
because no matter what words you say no
matter how much you tell people to be
positive again you're here watching this
you are the most positive person you're
and your family you're pouring into
other people no matter how much words
you use
what they'll be inspired by most is your
action
no matter how much you say hey love
yourself make this happen I believe in
you if they see you not believing in
yourself not taking the action you need
to take they'll never be inspired to do
it themselves either
they'll be most inspired by the actions
that you take when you're afraid and you
doubt yourself to it's time to make a
change let's make that change today
I think we play small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we haven't
trained in US
from a young age our parents our family
our friends our teachers think about who
did you learn about life from probably
people who didn't like their own life
you know who did you learn about careers
from probably people who did not have a
great career you know who barely are
enjoying what they're doing in their
work and they're living in scarcity
mindset of this is all I can do and
that's what we've learned from and you
know guidance counselors at school do
they love what they're doing I mean I
think this is a huge problem and we're
stuck living small and living scared and
living as a result way below our
potential of what we could do and who we
could help
I I think it's a big problem I think
lack of belief is the world's number one
problem when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working hard
or working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wants without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both and so
if you're not working hard then you
don't have a shot but assuming you are
working hard and you want a 10x again
then it's a shift in mindset and a shift
in living beliefs so how do you identify
the living beliefs how do you figure out
where it's holding your back how do you
break through the Paradigm and hit a new
level a lot of it is environmental
you know the the current thinking that
you have was environmental it's your
parents and your family and your
guidance counselor and teachers and
family Etc that's environmental you've
adopted their beliefs and unfortunately
a lot of them are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever is more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people uh every day
but you know we can't so how do you do
it well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter
and when somebody asked me yesterday on
Instagram do I think Elon Musk will buy
Twitter I said no I don't think you'll
buy Twitter but
it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
just in general right
is proving them wrong many many many
times and I just like the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically be
thinking through it if you're if you
were running Tesla uh in SpaceX would
you have thought about buying Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks so much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at it as a hey this is what's
possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if he
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove but the groove can also be a
rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expansive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them and Elon Musk a
John Azeroth Oprah Winfrey people who
who you may never meet but you can still
learn a heck of a lot from
step two was to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you're in that things that used to
make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
conference an event you come back I
wanna you ever gone away and come back
and wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just just think about if
you're just constantly stuck it doesn't
mean you have to go travel on vacation
it may mean you take up salsa dancing it
may mean you try a new hobby take that
idea that you've got and just go go to
it look at any events that are happening
in your city meetup groups conferences
clubs that you can join and be part of
to meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use uh
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class at you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same habit the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean I hey
if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know it's not Movie
Maker is something else but being around
other people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated I felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really struggled so find other
people who are on this journey that you
can do it with because when you feel
like you're doing it with other people
and you're not alone you'll be a lot
more productive a lot more effective and
have a lot more fun as well focus on one
idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12. most of
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
build to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms that you
also have a million other things that
you have to do and so as a result you're
you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much better it doesn't mean
that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether to social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself so that I can quit my job if you
have one so that I can bring income in
for myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money that then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helped me with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have uh family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big gold and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so that I can start making money and
start building momentum one last quick
example I look at a lot of thought
leaders a lot of people have a message a
lot of people want to be speakers and
authors and coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
uh getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
even selling courses your own materials
and training and Etc and coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you can do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
we just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus honestly I think we're all
thinking small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so because we
are products of our environment we have
conditioned ourselves to think the same
way as the people in our environment and
if you're not happy with your
environment and your environment is not
around around big people who've done
amazing things or thinking big then you
will stay stock thinking small as well
what I love about Naveen Jane is that he
thinks big you know the first time I
found this content there were three
people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch this top
10. his backup plan for his life was
being a minister and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing but Denzel Washington's a
whole other animal so he really blew me
away the second was Priyanka Chopra uh
who had a just amazing set of interviews
and super intelligent bright woman and
the third was Naveen Jane where I'd like
no idea who this person is you should do
Naveen Jane great go look him I was like
oh my gosh this guy's amazing I want
more Naveen Jane in my life
think that's a great sign you know like
when you find people like that even if
you've never met them and up until this
year I had never met Naveen Jane The
Good Fortune I just recently have him on
on my channel to do an interview in a
collaboration but up until that point
I'd never met him before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
be around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and it can still push me to become
better
and I think
a lot of us stay stuck and stay small
because it's so
good to feel important
and we end up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you're the one that's advising and
helping and pushing other people maybe
pushing them too much
does that make sense maybe you're maybe
you're pushing some people too much but
you're the most optimistic most
ambitious person in your circle probably
that's great in a sense and that you can
pour and give back and help others along
the way but who's pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you it's really uncomfortable to
think bigger
and if you don't have somebody inspiring
you pushing you helping you then you
probably stay stuck and that's what we
need to change and so it's a message for
you but it's a message for me equally so
and so step one in doing that I think is
just changing the environment to be
around the people who do inspire you and
chances are most of the people who do
inspire you are not not people who have
you have direct access to and not people
who are taking on an intern you know
Warren Buffett's not taking on an intern
to go live with him for a year as far as
I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much and been inspired
so much by just amazing people through
the content on my own channel like I
make these videos for me because I need
them because I need to believe more in
myself and then I share that with you
and thankfully enough of you like it
that I can make it a business and hire a
team and continue to make even more
content because if it was just me then
it'd be a lot fewer videos coming up and
a lot less profiles and a lot less
content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who's like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcasts be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level and this is why it's so great to
have so many people now I'm I'm
passionate about helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at uh Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life you know it's a hard push
they may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
then there'll be other people like Oprah
like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through it and
some people will hug you through it a
lot of times the message is exactly the
same you know Oprah's message is very
similar to Eric Thomas's message the
difference is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around it
more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow the same
person you were almost yesterday maybe a
half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you it's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are what you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you like saying these
words out loud it's like what changes do
I need to make to my environment who do
I need to be hanging out with more
either in person or just through the
video content to make me want to push
more be more courageous save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
right makes a big big difference and so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then you know it's just thinking bigger
then if you love Naveen Jane be around
Naveen Jane more
watch all those interviews and and
listen to any podcasts that he does and
I did one on my main Channel we'll link
that up at the end of this video you can
go watch if you want if you want to
improve your health and fitness and
you're tired of you know being on an
Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice in the decision
that I'm gonna I want to be this person
I want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and
that's awesome as a decision but you
need the environment to support you and
so now if you're subscribing to health
channels if you're following people on
Instagram who are working out and take
care of their bodies it will make you
want to live a healthier life one of the
ones that I love watching is Tom bilyu
and his health Theory show where he's
interviewing experts around health and
every time I listen I was listening to
one this morning every time I listen
watch it makes me want to be a little
bit healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
and then make a choice
change it
change who you subscribe to change what
you're listening and watching
unsubscribe from all the channels that
make you feel worse about yourself
change your physical environment what
what clothes are you wearing what do you
put on the wall around you what's your
background on your cell phone and on
your computer you start to change it and
when you change your environment
it'll Force the change in your habits in
your mindset and in your thinking your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you exactly where you
are right now the people you listen to
the media that you consume the habits
that you do daily all of them all of
them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years I've said Edwin you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people wanted it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
this designed to just photocopy Our
Lives over and over and over again so
how did I get it I paid more attention
to my environment I paid more attention
to my daily routines I paid more
attention to the people that I hang
around with it's important so looking at
my physical environment right look at
the look at this office look at the
people behind me this all means
something to me looking at the new
design that I've had here below putting
things like my neck braces it's down
below you can't really see it but this
inspires me I walk into this every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
the the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment
you need to change it because everything
you're doing right now is keeping you on
the path that you're on maybe there's
been some growth if you look at who you
were five years ago compared to now
you've grown if you're watching this
channel you've grown right you've made
some changes but is it drastic enough
like are you proud of where you're at
look at where you've come from in the
past year two years five years are you
proud of where you're at and are you
comfortable with that same level of
growth for the next five years if not if
you think I want more I want to help
faster I want to have a bigger impact
faster quicker then the fastest way to
do it is to change your environment so
that's you I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is cut out
negativity just cut out the people who
don't serve you sometimes those are
friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like there's this new skin none
of you that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
say I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become a
part of a co-working place can you be
around people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems and
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now
people they have problems you have
problems most people choose
entertainment as a way to forget about
their problems instead of Education as a
way to make their problems better do you
want to shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or do you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then Sun I like getting
Sun uh going outside being in nature
just having sun on my face not just
being stuck inside all day especially in
the morning makes a big difference my
third s is sore so I want to do
something makes me feel bold and come
alive and for me where I love my phone
here but for me I share a message I want
to share a message you want to feel like
the work that I do has meaning and
importance so I think about somebody
that I helped yesterday and then I share
a message on Instagram and Snapchat and
put it up that helps me soar what do you
need for yourself then I sweat so I'll
do a quick workout and then I do
something to scare myself right now it's
doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to meditate maybe you need to
pray maybe you need to pet your cat what
is the thing that you need to do to make
you feel bold and alive and and then
schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
if you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
because of other people because they may
see you because they may laugh at you
because they may say look at that person
they're so dumb right you're not afraid
of failing not not just by yourself
you're afraid of failing and who was
gonna watch and so that becomes really
important because it now
means you're living your life based off
of other people's expectations and
judgments and maybe that's
people in your own family maybe that's
people you know maybe that's your mom or
maybe that's random people you're afraid
of the Judgment of unknown YouTube
commenters and leaving some kind of
feedback on your video telling you how
much you suck right we're afraid of the
people that we care deeply about in
their perspective and opinions on us and
we're also afraid of the the people who
we don't know yet who are just out there
in the world on the internet who might
come and leave negativity on whatever
you're going to be creating so you're
not actually afraid of failing you'll do
it all the time but it's failing and who
is going to see us fail
and so
there's a lot to unpack inside of that
let's start with
what is your big goal what do you want
to accomplish what mission are you on
who are you trying to serve who you
trying to help and in order for you to
go off and accomplish those things and
serve to your highest capability you're
going to have to do things that will be
scary where you're going to risk failure
right if you are never risking any kind
of failure then you're living your life
so small and so safe that you don't like
your life
if there's nothing in your calendar in
the next month that you are excited by
the that your heart's getting you're
you're scared really you're nervous
right you're like oh my gosh that
thing's happening if there's nothing in
your calendar that's like that you don't
like your life that that's honestly most
people
you're just photocopying your same life
over and over and over and over and over
again that's what most people wake up
and do I'm sitting here in the Costco
parking lot right like most most people
you just wake up and you're photocopying
the same day you had yesterday and last
week and last year that's not a life
so you have to be willing to risk some
kind of failure which would potentially
risk other how other people see you and
judge you I used to not be able to
record videos like this I mean the first
video I ever recorded in public
was I was walking down the street at my
old house
and I was challenged by my agent he said
you have to record videos in public like
Steve make videos in public are you
crazy I can barely make videos at home
I'm gonna now make them in public like
you have to do it like okay great so I'm
walking down the street carrying my big
video camera at the time and
I made sure I picked the really quiet
section of the street where nobody was
usually outside because it made me feel
like I was recording the video and doing
the task but there was nobody around so
I wasn't really doing the task and I
remember there was a male male uh male
woman who was dropping off mail and as
soon as I saw her and I felt like I was
in auditory range of her then I pulled
the camera down
and then as I passed her I started
filming again
it's like I did the assignment Steve
look I filmed outside I didn't really do
the assignment but why because I'm
afraid of of a male woman's opinion of
me like she doesn't even care about me
she's she's living her life doing her
thing
and so something like this now I'm
sitting here in a parking lot filming
and people are walking by and some
people are watching like what's this guy
doing you keep going you just keep
making because fear of other people's
judgments cannot be a good enough reason
for you to play small not anymore and if
you want to do great things most of the
people judging you don't like their own
lives and any judgment they have of you
is just a reflection of self
so there's a couple of hacks that I've
used to be able to get through it that
might serve you
number one is studying successful people
and anytime you study successful people
you find out that they failed along the
way to their success
a lot of times you may just see on the
surface just their accomplishments and
list of what they've done and all that
and it could feel
um imposing you know how are they so
perfect and I suck and I have all these
fears and insecurities but if you look
deeper into their story and maybe watch
some of their interviews or videos
you'll see that they struggled a lot and
they had multiple failures on their path
to success and I used to before my
channel came out I used to read
stories of different famous
entrepreneurs and how they got started
and you know the kind of zero to one
story because it made me feel like
it was possible
that looking at Warren Buffett now is
crazy you know it's like he's done so
much you can't relate but how do you go
from zero to one and what did he
struggle with and where did he fail that
was inspiring to say hey okay if he
could get through that
now me decades later with a lot more
opportunity and technology and resources
and I could do that
you know I could do something similar so
that inspired me to to get out of my
cocoon and to be around people who are
doing amazing things inspired me to want
to go off and do more it's also why I
make videos like this so that you can
learn from Warren Buffett and all the
people that we profile and because I
think the more that you're around that
the more you'll win I don't know Warren
Buffett personally you probably don't
maybe you do maybe you can text him and
ask for advice I can't not yet but I can
watch his videos and I can learn from
him and I can get better and I can
improve Myself by being around him and
the more that I watch his videos the
more I can think like him just a little
bit and and that's important because
that shifts you forward so being around
more successful people will will shift
you towards success even if they are
virtual through through a computer
screen through videos podcasts books Etc
the second thing is
teaching myself that I do difficult
things
and I think that's really important
because we've accepted fear as a good
enough reason for you not to do the
thing you've accepted other people's
opinions as a good enough reason for you
not to do the thing my trigger words I
call them play bigger triggers you come
up with the triggers that will allow you
to play bigger so if I say scary
difficult or hard then I go off and do
it because I want to be the person who
does the things that are scary difficult
or hard to myself and that's why I still
make videos that's why I write books and
speak on stage and find all of those
things incredibly scary difficult and
hard
so what is it for you and when you can
stop accepting scary difficult or hard
as a good enough reason like I want to
do it but I'm scared okay well that's
not good enough reason you've already
set you've pre-decided that that's not a
good enough reason so you have to go up
and do the thing it's a scary difficult
heart you say it you write it you think
it you tell somebody else it as long as
that is the reason for you to put the
brakes on your life it's not a good
enough reason anymore it has to be
something stronger than scary difficult
or hard otherwise you have to go and
take action and you start to teach
yourself that you are the kind of person
who takes on things that are scary
difficult to hard so number one was
being around successful people
study them and learn from them and get
mentorship from them even if it's just
through a video number two is that you
do difficult things and then number
three is
focus on service
and if you understand that the thing
that you're afraid to do
is not just for you it's for other
people right if you're an entrepreneur
you're trying to create a business it's
not just for you this sure there's
selfish goals of I want to I want to
make money and provide for my family and
live a great life Etc but above that
needs to be service and helping others
that you're creating something that's
going to bring value to other people
that it's not just about you making
money but you're providing a real
service something really valuable to
other people that's going to make their
life better if I'm making videos it's
not just about me and numbers on the
channel it's about it's about you and
hopefully for for one of you watching
this video it has a big impact today
when I speak on Sage or write the Books
it's not about me it's about who I can
help serve and whenever you can deeply
connect to who you can help serve
at least for me it gives me the courage
to go off and do the thing if I'm
terrified to speak on stage
I'll often look behind the curtain at
the audience and I'll try to find a
couple people like I'm doing it for that
person I'm doing it for him I'm doing
for her I've got a message that I can
share that can help them and that you
gives me the confidence and the courage
to go do the thing because we'll show up
for other people more than we'll show up
for ourselves and so when you can tie
what you're doing to other people to
Value to service to helping them it'll
give you more confidence and courage to
go off and do the thing that you need to
do and so I call that the push and the
hug so
the I do difficult things I do scary
things is the push like get out get out
there and do this Carmichael let's go
and the service is the hug like hey I'm
not I'm not doing this just for me I'm
doing it for for all the people out
there as well and some days you need
more of the hug some days you need more
of the push
and you just lean in on what you feel
you need most you know there are some
days when pushing yourself harder is not
the answer you need a hug and there are
some days where hugging yourself more is
not the answer you need to push
and so having a self-awareness and now
okay I need the push right now or I need
the hug right now and then going off and
doing that will give you the momentum
that you need
failure
failure is gonna happen
and the biggest failure again is that
the fear of other people seeing you fail
and as long as you live your life by the
expectations of other people you will
live small forever
and if you can flip it to say I'm doing
this to help others I'm doing this
because
I want to live a great life and I'm
doing this because I do difficult things
when you can make that shift happen you
start to accomplish your goals people
aren't afraid of failing you're afraid
of failing in front of other people
you'll sing in the shower but you won't
sing on the street corner you'll record
a video but you'll never release it
you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy if one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge you the event and My First
Reactions oh my God I can't charge this
event right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason that I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free well the tour this
year shouldn't be free and so I had to
do it I had to step into the fear you
have to step into the fear and do it
because you need to attack the thing
that you're afraid of especially when
it's related to other people right I'm
not afraid of failing I'm afraid of
failing in front of other people right I
I can suck all day here in the office
but I don't want to suck in front of
somebody else I don't want to make
people feel like whether they're
spending 50 bucks to come and see me
that was on tour or 2 000 bucks to come
see me at my thought Lucifer out of me
here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur makes you a thousand times
better as an entrepreneur because that's
the same fear that you face in your
business that fear of going on that game
show on the cruise ship that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
if you come on the other side you'll
come up with more strength and then
you'll start seeing things happen in
your business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you have
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness
I don't think people are bold all day
long right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness you
have these moments these spikes these
hits right you go to an event I look at
people come to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you
those are the decisions you have to
follow through on and embrace and then
your head talks you down from them the
head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to do it you have to start
building momentum you have to start
committing to some other people embrace
the Bold ideas recognize that those
aren't the crazy ideas those crazy ideas
that come up with your feeling bold are
not crazy those are actually the best
ones for you you're just buried under a
pile of garbage of limited beliefs on
top of you those are the things you have
to go chase down and when it gets hard
when it gets difficult when you want to
quit remind yourself this idea came to
me when I was feeling bold I have to do
it because I do bold things you teach
yourself step number two is expect to
suck this is where it gets super
liberating expect to suck the first time
you do anything expect to suck why do
you expect to be great the first time
out what do you expect your first video
that you make to be great it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
and making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long your first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill kill you suck at the
beginning and it's really hard because
you know what looks good if you want to
be a basketball player you know what a
good basketball player looks like if you
want to be a YouTuber you know what a
good YouTube video looks like but then
you can't do it yet your first one sucks
and that's where most people quit
because they expect to be good they're
worried about looking bad in front of
them people they're not good the first
time out and so then they never go back
to it and this is what happens when when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying
as adults how often do you try new
things how often are you willing to risk
failure to risk losing to risk looking
like a fool
you don't want them so you're not trying
as much anymore and you ever find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life and some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love
expect to suck but if you love the
process of it you will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you forgot
but this thing that you remember the
stuff that you connected with
it so when you love something you're
learning a lot faster
you like something you're going to get
better a lot faster even if you suck at
the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos but I'm trying my best maybe it's
not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying I'm proud of my
effort I'm proud of the attempt most
people tie their software to winning to
the results to the money to the gold
medal to the to the whatever right to
the YouTube to the plaques back there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself Worth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you can you're
capable of way more you keep both doing
something much bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing
and then you have these big ones
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're part of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because we're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing you're only risk looking
like an idiot
you have to if you want the life that
you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
but get up try again be proud of your
effort every single day as an introvert
Making Connections always seemed
incredibly scary to me I hate going to
networking events I'm not life of a
party I don't know how to approach
people and ask them questions and it
always just felt I think at the end of
the day very fake and inauthentic and
just not me you know I don't know how to
introduce myself and I don't know I
don't know what to talk about I want to
sit here and talk I'm here in Arizona
and it's beautiful and it's sunny and
it's amazing but I don't I don't I don't
want to just talk about the weather you
know I don't want to talk about boring
superficial stuff and
it took me a long time to get
comfortable coming to events and I'm
this is actually a great moment because
I'm here at genius Network
um it's a I just came out of a two-day
event where people are paying 25 000 to
be part of and the next two days uh it's
another event where they're paying 100
000 to be part of and I'm a guest here
speaking at um at both events and I
would have I would have never like
younger Evan would have never come to
something like this because
not that it's not valuable just I would
have been too afraid to to network and
to uh to ask for help and to introduce
myself and all of those things what I've
discovered if you're an introvert
what I've discovered is that introverts
are great listeners
and we care
and you can be a fantastic networker if
you're an introvert but your goal is not
to know the entire room and the goal is
not to run into the the the event and
say look at me here's what I do and
where the shiniest suit and be the
loudmouth if that's you awesome roll
with it but if it's not your goal is to
just connect with a few people on a
really meaningful level
I've connected over the past couple days
with some amazing people who've given me
some amazing advice and connections and
experiences and
just amazing people but it hasn't been I
don't there's lots of people who I
haven't connected with
you know there were maybe
50 people here over the past two days
and in the bigger the more expensive
group I think there's 30 people or 20
people coming and I probably won't get
to talk to everybody
um probably not I mean maybe
but I'm not I'm not I I'm not judging
myself for not knowing everybody I'm not
judging myself for
how many business cards I leave with oh
the people you still use business cards
I don't have any business cards I'm not
judging myself by if I connected with
them or not it's more I'd rather spend
time with a few people
who I can connect with on some kind of
level and
that ends up leading to so much better
things Joe polish is the guy who runs
this so this is his office and he's the
one who puts his events together and
he's he's known as the most connected
man in the world right some of his bios
and websites will say people talk about
him he's the most connected man in the
world in hanging around him for the past
few days I can understand why so if
we're going to reverse engineer
Joe polish's success and he'll he'll say
that he's you know on the introverted
side
um
he's invited me to his home
he's I came in a couple days early and
helped him with his team and His Channel
and he invited me to stay at his home
today's our day off in between the two
events and he's invited me to go work
out with him and go do some IVs with
vitamins in it and go sit in a hot sauna
then jump in a nice cold bath and ask me
how I'm doing and what I'm up to and if
I need if I need anything or if I want
to use his office I mean I'm using I'm
using his office I guess the outside the
film today it's too beautiful today not
to film outside but but whatever I need
it doesn't just do that for anybody you
know he's not just going to open up his
home for anybody
and he's really trying to spend time
think about me if I would do that and I
think man probably not and so that's
that's maybe a learning for me because
I've run events I've hosted my own
events and they usually just knock me
out when I when I posted my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it would
knock me out I mean the last day of one
of the um
the last day of my event I remember I I
passed out like I had a break of 15
minutes and I I passed out and fell
asleep on a floor like on my dance floor
because I was giving so much and then my
my body gave out on me
and so I couldn't imagine then also like
Joe's got such a crazy week think about
how much people are paying him right
they pay him twenty five thousand
dollars for
the event that just finished and then a
hundred thousand dollars for the event
that's coming up
you gotta deliver some value right if
people are coming and they're paying a
hundred thousand dollars to be here that
that's
got to be at least for me incredibly
stressful to do that and while he's in
the middle of all of that he's worried
about me and how I'm doing and if I want
to stay with him and if I need to if I
want to go do some vitamin IVs and if
I'm being looked after if I need an
internet connection or a place to work
and the amount of text that he sent
while he's
in the sauna or working out or
doing his meetings
I was like how are you still thinking
about me you've got you've got
so much going on I I don't I mean it's
something that that I'm honestly
inspired by and I find aspirational
but he does it so well
and it's like he can't do that for
everybody and so uh you know I'm
grateful I guess that he saw something
in me that he'd want to spend that kind
of time with
but he's very selective over who he
brings in and then once you're in he's
gonna be the greatest resource of all
time and I think that's how you win
ultimately at least for me I think it's
a fantastic model for me to learn from
and keep trying to do better at and that
how can you win as an introvert when you
are networking
and trying to help people
introverts are great listeners
introverts care we want to help we want
to serve and we can't do it for
everybody because we let too many people
in we then we have no energy for
ourselves
and recognize that that's how you you
that's your secret superpower
let's do superpower
use superpower my superpower is to find
just a few people
at every place you go to your goal is
not to meet the whole event it's made a
few people
and figure out how you can help them and
genuinely help them like generally serve
them not not just if I help them do this
and they're gonna help me do that right
we're not don't don't approach it as a
transaction I think introverts are great
at this right it's not on transaction
you we value relationships
but are too afraid to go up and say hi
to people and don't like the The Fluffy
talk
so just make it a goal to find a few
people
and be of service and great things
happen
one of the things I've taken away and
just reinforced from the past couple
days is great things happen to me
and I'm I'm actually becoming less of a
goal person like where do you want to be
next year I have no idea because great
things happen to me
because if you keep pouring into other
people and keep bringing value and keep
helping
great things will happen to you that you
you never thought of
you know that you never thought would
exist and yet here they are now showing
up in your life
and so a challenge for you would be to
think about
whether it's the next event you're going
to or even just some people in your
network
like who do you already know
who are good people
be in the business of collecting good
people like who do you already know
who's a good person who you
you want to serve and help on a deeper
level
and just find a way to reach out and
help them
be of service I make a list of of the
top kind of 100 people that I want to
stay in touch with because I'll forget
I'll forget to stay in touch and two
present-minded Focus but if I haven't
stayed in touch with them in the past 90
days I'll find some some way to help
whether it's
sharing something on social whether it's
making a video giving them some YouTube
advice does just connecting asking how
it can be a resource
I schedule in the ongoing connection
because
these people have helped me a lot and I
want to continue to help them and if
you're just going strategy you know
continue to help successful people will
lead to you having more success because
it will they will find ways to come back
and help you you're almost guilting them
to do it even better is to not even be
as strategic about it
just by putting out good energy just by
serving others just by using that good
karma it comes
and in the process of giving if you can
remind yourself that great things happen
to you
that if I just keep showing up and
serving and helping and doing my very
best every day
great things will happen to me great
things will happen to you great things
will happen to you
you just have to keep going your
challenges don't only make you stronger
they allow you to serve better I think
the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that I put in your way allow you to have
a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor they're built to serve
you are built to serve when you can
connect the challenge that you're going
through as something that's then going
to inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to it just being about me
getting stronger I find a lot of times
me getting stronger is not enough it's
not enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
it was great for speaking but it sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues things like believing you're not
good enough lack of self-worth you don't
have a message to share imposter
syndrome all of those things right even
here we're filming we're about to go
through a car wash uh we're we're next
so we're probably gonna get some crazy
noise I have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next you guys can see this is this
car wash or next depending on how long
that guy ahead of us takes you might you
might see it in this video I dealt with
a lot of those mindset issues those lack
of belief issues those worthiness issues
and I I battled them and I've been
through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did the path can
be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I'd never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
uh I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run and I was
doing Instagram live at the times like a
light run fast Jog and I like my toe was
hurting so much and I just kept powering
through I didn't later realize I broke
my toe but that's not really anything
major right you know if somebody's going
through something physical and major
it's like you broke your toe come on
it's not a big deal and so I never felt
like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through it and I don't
feel right pushing people on things that
I haven't experienced in some form
myself right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potential having spinal surgery which is
crazy scary but also not being able to
think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was it
was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations the biggest difference
between you and the people who you look
up to are that they started
and you're still thinking about it it's
one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that I deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seen so much heart and love and
care is like you you could be serving so
much and helping so much and having such
a big impact
and and we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the the perfect cameraman
my first video if you go back and watch
it on my channel I had my friend come
and film it and record it for me because
I was worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup and I I memorized
the script because I didn't want to say
the wrong words I had to be perfect uh
most of my early videos were were still
mostly voice over because I could write
a script and have it perfect and just
have b-roll and it wouldn't be me on
camera afraid of making a mistake and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow you know if
you look at my journey of
making what for five years seven
thousand subscribers something like that
it was I was stuck I was I was
I was too afraid to do the next thing I
was too afraid to get in the race I was
making content at least I was one decent
thing for whatever reason I stay
consistent on on doing stuff but I was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and a lot of
you are already way better than than I
was when I started
and when I'm on interviews and I'm I'm
doing events and presentations and I see
the audience and I see who's there and I
see the skill and the and the heart just
the this is the thing that kills me the
most it's like the hearts like you want
you've got such a good heart you want to
do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear
if you could make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
or the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going
so when people ask me should I should I
do this business or this business should
I do that business or this one's like
well I don't know you know like at the
end of the day it's gonna be what you
love doing all of them could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's going to be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like coffee or not you know you have to
go off and you take a sip
and then you find out you can't think
your way through this so you can't think
your way you can have some planning but
the planning won't save you at the end
of the day you have to go off and just
do something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so
let's make it practical let me just give
you some steps for how to actually get
in the race and start taking some action
step one
understand or at least tell yourself
that great ideas flow through you
great ideas flow through you that
because you came up with the idea that
it's a good idea stop judging it stop
telling yourself you suck stop telling
yourself someone like you can't do it
like great ideas flow through you this
is a good idea you need to go do
something about it right even just
telling yourself that shortcuts the fear
because all of the reasons in your head
for why you can't do it is really just
fear if you think about making content
and you're worried about the microphone
and the camera and the gear and all that
that's just fear talking it's just
you're afraid that it won't be good and
so you're trying to cover your bases and
we come up with all these logical
reasons why we can't do it but really
just fear talking so cut through the
fear by telling yourself that great
ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later still stuck in the
same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us are are stuck in an
action because we're Paralyzed by fear
and we've come up with rational reasons
why we can't do the thing you're not
changing because you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to do
it all alone you can have a moment of
inspiration moment of this is the day
I'm gonna change it all and then when
your environment and the people around
you don't support you in doing it and
you're doing it all alone you lose
momentum the next day that momentum is
gone and the next day the momentum is is
absolutely zero have you ever you ever
been there until you get the people
around you to support you to create a
circle where you can feel like you do
not have to do this alone
you won't change and you'll stay stuck
knowing that you're capable of more
and frustrated with yourself with the
lack of momentum I run this challenge
inside my movement makers program and
every month we have to talk about a
certain topic movement makers is For
Thought leaders it's people who are they
have a message they have a mission they
want to get out to the world your story
matters let's get it out there and go
come on
but it's really hard to share your story
and it's really hard to make videos and
it's really hard to put yourself out
there and you have these moments where
you want to do it and you feel on top of
the world like yes I'm ready and then
and then what then all the insecurities
and fears and doubts creep in and
as I was noticing people and Movie
Makers not making enough content I
decided to do a challenge and the
challenge is once a month we pick a
topic
and this month's topic is courage
and what you have to do is make a solo
video that's 10 minutes long you have to
make a lead magnet to help grow your
business and you have to do three
collaboration videos and most people do
Instagram lives to collaborate with each
other and all of a sudden
people who took up the challenge started
making content all of a sudden the
excuses went away the I don't know what
gear to buy I don't know what camera to
use I don't know what microphone I don't
know what to talk about my story is not
good enough I'll start next week I'll
start next year I'll start next month
I'll start on my birthday I'll start on
January 1st I'll start on Monday I'll
start I'll start next month right all of
the all of the excuses all of a sudden
went away
because you're not doing it alone
because all of those reasons that are
holding people back that are holding you
back you want to do something bigger
all of the reasons that are actually
holding you back are not The Logical
ones that are in your head
right the idea that you're not making
content because you don't know what
phone to use or what camera to use or
what I'm sit I'm making these videos for
my channel on my phone I'm I'm in my car
at my wife's uh acupuncturist she's
getting acupuncture done right now in
the building right next to me and so I'm
making content in my car you can too
right they're logical reasons why you
are not doing a thing that you want to
do right that you say is important to
you there's logical reasons that you are
buying
you've you've you believe them they are
actual reasons but they're not good
enough reasons and underneath those
reasons why you're not doing the thing
that you need to do is just that you're
afraid
it's just fear
and suffering through fear alone
is really really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's not that you can't do
it it's just
immensely difficult and most people
won't most people won't follow through
most people don't follow through because
they are alone
in this journey you might have people
around you you might you might have
great parents friends uh a spouse but if
you feel like you're walking the journey
all by yourself
just insanely difficult to actually
follow through and get the results that
you want
good news is you
can change your circle and I'm going to
share a couple ideas in this video of
how to do it so
number one
I like to collect good people
collect good people think about the
people around you in your life how many
of them make you feel happier more
energetic more positive and you may not
have many people you know there you may
not have someone like that great
think about the people who you've ever
met
maybe it was at a conference maybe an
event maybe a lunch or dinner some kind
of party a friend of a friend
I
find ways to spend more time with good
people I remind myself that I like to
collect good people and as someone who's
shy and introverted
that's that's
not my default state
I don't think to call people I don't
think the message people I don't I don't
um default to being around people but
when there's somebody who's energy I
really love and I leave the conversation
feeling more uplifted than when I went
in
then I I try to find ways to spend more
time with that person and maybe it leads
to a business maybe it leads to some
kind of opportunity maybe just leads to
another conversation but think about the
people who you have met at some point in
your life maybe not the people around
you right now but an old high school
friend or again somebody at an event or
a club or some meeting that you met that
you really like their energy and their
Vibe I'll lean in on the awkward and say
hey do you want to go grab a coffee I'd
love to learn more about your story
or I really love your energy
do you want to go and get some lunch
together
it feels super awkward but chances are
they need somebody too
and if you be the first one to do the
Outreach and say hey I'd love to learn
more about you see the people who you
don't really know that well but you'd
like to
and you can even say that when you're
talking to them hey I don't really know
you that well but I'd like to
and lean in on the awkwardness be the
first one to go off and do it so so
think about the people in your network
people who you have met one-offs
meetings
who filled you with that positivity and
and fight for more time with them
because if you had four people
and you met everybody once a month
that's once a week now you're meeting
some amazing human
whether it's coffee whether it's lunch
whether it's a zoom call whether it's
actually forming some kind of business
together
there are people who you've come across
who
are the support that you need and you
need to do the Outreach to say hey I'd
like to get to know you a little bit
better and spend a little more time with
you
leaning on the awkwardness collect good
people test number one two is you change
your environment to be around the people
even if you can't meet them so watching
this video is a great example watch this
video did you wake up this morning
you're like yeah my gosh so amazing
let's go crush the day
right I didn't if you
if I'm super jealous of you you probably
woke up and you're tired and you look at
your phone and what's on my calendar for
today and immediately some of the
limiting beliefs and thoughts and
attitudes uh popped in your head and so
if you can't be around the people every
day you know the collective people if
you can't be around them every day then
you can be around them virtually
through videos through YouTube through
books through uh social media follow the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and make you want to go off and
Conquer your goals
most of the time when people are
spending time on social media YouTube
Instagram Etc
how much of that time is spent actually
learning and being inspired versus
wasting time
how many times have you opened your
phone went to a social media app and all
of a sudden 40 minutes went by you
didn't even notice because you're just
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
right has that happened
that's that's that's not what you want
to do
don't lean in on that right audit right
now audit who you are subscribed to on
YouTube and who you're following on
Instagram and ask yourself do these
people make me feel better about myself
or not
do I leave feeling more inspired than
when I came in and if no then unfollow
those people and good news there's lots
of amazing people not just me there's
tons of amazing people who are making
amazing content
and whatever you want to learn whatever
you want to get more into
when you can surround yourself even in a
social media environment if you wanted
to work out more if you followed a whole
bunch of Fitness people people who are
working out constantly people who are
not you're making excuses for why they
can't get to the gym today if you
followed all those people it's now in
your environment you'll start to see it
more often it'll become it'll become
that daily reminder for you and you're
more likely to go to the gym and work
out so whatever you want to be whoever
you want to be whatever your goals are
choose to follow the people who are
achieving those goals who are living
that because it's not your identity yet
and for them it is and the more you're
around that they will suck you in to be
like them so choose very carefully what
you want to get sucked into right it can
also lead down a really negative dark
path right whoever's more confident in
their beliefs wins if you're around
people who are strongly believing in
something that is that is bad or evil or
you know against your core values you
know you could be sucked down a really
dark negative hole as well so Step One
is collect good people step two is to be
around them be around in social media
with intention the people who make you
feel better about yourself and and go
achieve your goals and the step three is
to join some kind of community join some
kind of group uh who are focused in on
on what you're trying to do so if you
wanna
if you want to get into fitness then you
you can hire a coach to help your
fitness trainer or join a gym or join
some kind of collective where you feel
like you don't have to do this by
yourself why movement makers is so
special is because if you want to be a
thought leader where do you go where do
you go to hang out with other thought
leaders
right nowhere do you know anybody who's
a thought leader is trying to make great
content and share it and have a message
to give to the world you know who who
else that you know in your life talks
like that probably not right so being
around that and and whatever it is that
you want to learn you want to be better
at chess then join a chess club and hire
a chess coach be around the people
be around the people join some kind of
community so you don't have to do this
all alone one of the things that I
struggled the most with is feeling like
I have to come up with all the ideas
myself carrying everything on my back
and what I realized
varied later in my entrepreneurial
Journey right I mean I'm I'm
what I'm 40 how old am I now 40 I'm
almost 42 when I'm filming this video my
first Real Business and Entrepreneurship
when I was 19. so it's been a while you
know 20 plus years of being an
entrepreneur
uh not including like garage sales and
that kind of stuff
and one of the hardest things for me was
just not trying to have to do everything
myself not putting all the pressure on
myself to have to do everything
everything everything all by myself
I like to say movement makers that one
plus one equals four thousand you know
like you come in
and not just movement makers but any
anytime you do this any any club you
join or group you join especially if
you're a giver givers have a hard time
asking but when you're with other givers
they want to pour into you they want to
give to you they want to see you win as
well so you come in hoping to get
something and then when you get that
plus you can contribute to other people
and what they're doing and see that
you're showing up for them also allows
them to go off and accomplish their
goals
it's just such a great cycle
and it's such a weight lifted to know
that you don't have to do everything all
by yourself
so you could be willing to change you
could have these great Ambitions and
great ideas of who you could be and who
you want to be and the impact that you
want to have
but it's not going to happen until you
realize that you can't do this alone
stop trying to do this alone stop trying
to do everything yourself
you can change people will support you
but it's on you to collect good people
to audit who you follow on social media
into join a group of people who are
like-minded
if you want to make one single change
this year
that will have a tremendous impact on
the growth of you actually accomplishing
your goals
decide to not do this alone anymore the
fastest way to change your habits is to
change your environment you ever notice
how when you're in a different
environment maybe you go on vacation
maybe you go to an event or seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars or those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too this morning I was talking to a
YouTuber big YouTuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different Niche and I remember meeting
him in California
a couple years ago and one of the things
he was struggling with was staying
consistent and I'm very consistent and
one of the things I was struggling with
was staying healthy while I was on the
road and we're having dinner together
and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and I probably had a burger or something
fries and
coming away from that what I realized
was
whoever is more confident wins and when
you're around other people whoever's
more confident in the habit that they
have will be the dominant habit that
both of you end up picking up so if we
were hanging out together more here's
what would happen I would become a lot
healthier in my eating and he would
become a lot more consistent in his
content because we'd be inspired by each
other because he'd see me working with
make my videos and he'd feel bad that he
was making his and he'd have to go and
start making his and I see him eating
healthy all the time like man I should
be eating healthy and they would force
me to do it as well that environment
switch would allow us to create much
better stronger habits so now you got to
be careful about the kind of people who
you're hanging out with and if you look
at the people you've got right now
around you chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them support
into them you're you're taking your cup
and pointing to them and it's great and
it's and you should keep doing that and
it's amazing and it's it's fulfilling
but who's pointing to you and who's
making you get to the next step because
if you don't have that you're gonna
you're gonna continue to stay small or
just have slow growth compared to where
you could be so how do we get some
practical steps okay that's great what
do we actually do how do you start
making that change happen well the first
step is to figure out what is it that
you want to get better at you know what
area of your life or business do you
want to be better at is it you want to
stay more consistent on your habits you
want to you want to learn how to make
money you want to have a better
relationship you want to take care of
your health like what is the thing that
you actually want to get better on
getting Clarity on what that thing is
two is to then surround yourself as much
as possible with
with content not even people because it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around Joe dispense all the time and you
will you will become better you will
meditate more you will solve your
awesome but you don't know Joe dispenser
and he's probably not taking on students
right now or mentees right or Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey whoever right you don't
know them and so that's not a practical
answer but you can hang around their
content
that's why I make these videos every day
because if every day there was a new
video for you hopefully it lifts you to
bring some of the best experts in the
world the people that I find inspiring
and learn from to share their message
every morning you don't have that person
in your life but there's videos for you
so step two is step one we're figuring
out what is it that we want right where
do we want to improve and get better
step two is who are the people who are
who are living it who are preaching it
who are living it who actually inspire
you and there's so many different people
out there who are doing it and everybody
has their own way I like to say that you
know an Aaron Thomas is going to yell at
you through it and Oprah Winfrey is
going to hug you through it but they
have very similar messages
whoever style you connect with the most
have that more consistently in your
environment follow them on Instagram
subscribe to them on YouTube put their
quotes on the wall around you create
your own environment of the people who
make you feel like you want to do more
to inspire you to step out of your
comfort zone and take on those new
habits that you want to actually adopt
right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with Joe dispenza or Elon
musker Oprah Winfrey
okay so I call them aspirational mentors
and and that can be fundamental and
that's where most people need to start
because you have access to their books
and their videos and their content you
have that access right now and that can
make a big shift in you if you start
surrounding yourself with it every day
and then step three is to is to get more
in-person connections and this is more
time consuming and more challenging and
harder to find the right fits but
can make a big shift as well in your
life so I don't want to only rely on it
that's why step two is actually having
just content that you're learning from
but step three if there's people that
you're learning from do they have an
event do they have something coming up
can you hang around people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges I'm doing a challenge right
now inside my movement makers program
where Movie Makers is For Thought
leaders who are trying to get to the
next level with their content and break
through and have a greater message and
reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have because
they're the only ones doing this they
don't know anybody else making content
their family thinks they're crazy like
why are you making another video they're
not seeing results that they don't have
a peer group they don't have anybody to
connect with and talk to and
this can relate to any goal that you
have movement makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our Movie Makers challenge is
every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to start
making content and for a lot of the
members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though a lot of the content
that you make
um outside will still be separate from
the members you're not doing a business
together but it feels like they're
connected we're taking on this challenge
together and then in the collaboration
videos you're you're connecting with
people you're doing interviews with
people you're you're sharing your
thoughts and feedback it's not just you
talking to a camera in the car with your
dogs by yourself anymore
it really
really so getting some kind of support
group connecting with the people who are
on the same Journey going to seminars or
events of of humans that you can talk to
and connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do because the more
that you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life
it's it's entirely possible and if
you're watching videos like this you're
you're already on the growth mindset
Journey right you're already into
personal development you already know
you want to do more and serve more and
help more and this helps you elevate
yourself to the next level because you
are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can one clearly
identify what you want to change what is
the Habit that you want to take on where
are you not satisfied anymore in your
life not beating yourself up and saying
you suck but like the next level of
growth that you want to accomplish
yourself and then two following people
just through content who are living that
message who are who are not just
speaking it but living it who who when
you watch their their videos you
actually get inspired to go make a
change in your life who are those people
subscribe to them follow them every day
watch their content read their books put
their stuff up on your wall as a
reminder you're creating a new
environment for yourself and then three
is actually connecting with humans
joining a group like mover makers or
something else going to events where
your your tribe is at so that you are
not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like you don't belong make
those three changes it will change your
life the difference between where you
are now where you could be is just the
consistent habits that you're putting in
you know this I know you know this now
it's about taking the actual action to
stay consistent on those habits my key
to being productive is doing different
things on different days different
activities different energy states on
different days if you feel like you're
getting to the end of the day or getting
to the end of the week and you're
working like crazy like you're working
you you were not sucking off you're
working like crazy and yet nothing
seemed to happen have you gotten there
it's like I did so much work this week
and yet I've moved very little towards
actually accomplishing my goals if
that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what I do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days I'll
break down for you what I do every day
of the week
Monday is my mentoring day Mondays are
the days where I spend mentoring my team
and you've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people who have
invested into as well in their companies
and Monday I just spend the whole day
talking to them all I have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
Tuesday is YouTube day so today I'm
filming on a Tuesday I don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a Tuesday for me filming all I have
to worry about on a Tuesday is making
YouTube content and why it's so
productive these days is because it
takes a while to make the first video it
takes a while to do the first call takes
a while to get momentum going but once
you get the momentum going
it's easier to stay in the momentum than
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's YouTube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like I
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right Vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
it takes it takes a while to get the
Mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video I could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
intermediate intermediate I want to say
sequential that's not a word succession
succession intermediate succession
whatever
hahaha after I can make three or four
more videos right after while I'm in
that same Vibe so same thing for you
whatever Vibe you're feeling if you can
stay in that energy Zone instead of
switching if I did YouTube video then
write in a book then doing a phone call
then measure my team then you're just
bouncing around too much in this high
high high energy switching costs that
then keep you unproductive then this is
I mean a huge unlock because when you
can figure out how to chunk your time
like this brain fog goes away
productivity dramatically increases you
suddenly have a lot more free time as
well to do whatever you want to do Nina
is back she's in the house we are at
Nina's acupuncture let me put my
seatbelt on as we well as we get ready
to go
so Tuesday's YouTube day and I spend the
whole day making videos Wednesday is
Project day and on Project day I focus
on whatever projects I want to work on
and it's
I wake up in the morning I look at what
do I want to work on today and it's a
it's a lot more of a creative day
Tuesdays and Thursdays are very intense
productive days Wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what I had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive so judge
myself harshly when I was working on a
new project and it would take me a long
time and I felt like I got nothing done
that's okay creativity is not meant to
be efficient
so you won't be efficient on your
creative days on your creative tasks it
won't be efficient for you but that's
okay and I think you need to have
creative time built into your calendar
because if you're only doing things that
are productive you're going to burn out
you're going to hit your life and you're
gonna feel Limited you ever get bored of
your own business you get bored of the
things you're doing well there's not
enough creative time planned into your
week when do you get time to work on new
fun things that maybe pay off maybe
don't pay off when you have time to work
on that well you don't okay so that's
when people have midlife crisis or
burnout or want to throw it all away or
quit or stop doing this thing and so I
think you have to have some highly
productive days where you're really
working on achieving the goals that you
know I have to get these things done and
then you have to have some creative days
where you get to focus on whatever
projects you want that you're not
judging yourself harshly for being you
know not very efficient creativity is
messy it's designed to be that way and
you need to have some creative days in
your calendar or you will get tired of
your business and hate your life so
that's Wednesday Wednesday's creative
Day project day Thursday is public
facing day and Thursdays
I'm usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and I'm
I'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but I am and
it takes me a while to to get into the
zone of being around other people
[Laughter]
so on Thursdays I start with my family
and movement makers are my community of
thought leaders are trying to build
their business and get their message to
the world and Brent Linux is my
community of people on YouTube who want
to build their YouTube channel up
specifically and want the advice to to
grow and create and so I start my
Thursdays with them because it's it's
family it's safe it's friendly it's warm
and it makes me feel like what I do
matters and is important and then the
rest of Thursday is interviews and
podcasts and in Zoom calls and just all
day spreading the message
spreading the message you know we got we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because I just came from movement makers
or brand Linux
so I'm already in the in the zone of
sharing and creating and impacting and
seeing smiles and so I carry that energy
into my next interview on my next
podcast and the next thing that I'm
doing so if I'm booking to be on other
people's shows even if I'm booking for
my own show Thursdays it's always on a
Thursday it's always on a Thursday it's
always on a Thursday and I have five
minute breaks in between so it's usually
25 minutes or 55 minutes and then five
minute break and then on to the next one
on to the next one and so it's really
easy and all of a sudden it's seven
o'clock and
what happened to today I don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
YouTube video or then go and wrap my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a Wednesday
it took me an hour just to get into
remembering what I did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where I left off last time
uh since there's a public-facing day
Friday is CEO day so that's what do we
need to do to grow my business you know
what what are the big projects instead
of working in my business work on the
business so Wednesday's work in the
business on Creative projects Friday is
if I'm going to be the CEO of my
business what does that look like what
do I need to be doing because if you're
an entrepreneur you're you're the CEO
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show and we have to
do a lot of things to drive the business
forward we have to be in our business we
don't have a giant team yet even at 37
people I do a lot of work in the
business as opposed to only just being
the CEO and just managing and truthfully
I like being in the business I like like
making videos like this is not CEO time
this is me being in the business but I
like it you know I think I think people
who often just be the CEO if you're
entrepreneurial and there's no projects
you're working on uh you you grow
distant from the business you don't
enjoy it so we all need time in our
calendar every week to focus on being
the CEO and now I spend all my Fridays
doing it at the beginning I just started
with two hours so two hours in my
calendar okay this is my CEO time and I
blocked it off and it made it important
and when I started doing that I started
seeing more results in my company
Saturday we applied to the weekends too
Saturday is fun day so Saturday spending
time with Nia doing whatever you know
going it's starting to get warm here in
Canada you can you can see you know the
grass finally green so if we're going
for a hike or trying out a restaurant or
going to uh street festival or just
something fun Sunday is family at midday
so all of the stuff that we have to do
to manage the family you know go grocery
shopping fold laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
Sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary Monday is mentoring
day Tuesday is YouTube day Wednesday's
project day Thursday is public facing
day Friday CEO day Saturday fun day and
Sunday is family admin day and that fits
my life
you know that's a calendar for my life
it won't photocopy perfectly over to
yours but the key is to chunk your time
and think about what is a balanced life
look like for me so that
I'm happy I'm creative I'm productive
I'm moving closer to becoming the person
that I want to be and if you can't
control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh I can't I can't completely control my
day I can't have a YouTube day okay
don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through Instagram posts or
YouTube videos mindlessly that that
you're you're there with intention and
you're gonna you have so many you have a
certain amount of controllable hours I
think part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know
be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the Allure being
an entrepreneur is that freedom but if
you're not completely there yet you
still have controllable hours when you
get home from work to the time you go to
bed when you wake up to the time you go
to work and then on weekends you have
controllable hours
be more intentional with them
and decide what is the life that you
want to live that'll come down to then
the habits that you're executing on
daily which comes down to your calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
Zone instead of switching between a
million different tasks every day it
allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier and allows you
to get a lot closer to your goals you
don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing that keeps you
stuck keeps you small keeps you
frustrated keeps you knowing that you're
capable of more and being too afraid to
go take the action and until you can
break that pattern of negative self-talk
will happen and so we're going to fix
that in this video I think as soon as we
come up with ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
going to happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out of
fear of being seen fear of not being
seen
and it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
I've made I don't know how many twelve
thousand thirteen thousand fourteen
thousand videos some crazy number of
videos and yet every time before I sit
down to make the videos I procrastinate
a little bit in today's filming session
I'm here at my wife's Acupuncture Clinic
she's inside getting her acupuncture
done I joined her sitting in the car and
it probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time you ever had these
thoughts you know like you want to do
something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you have a new ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know has that happened I
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
it is a little longer I'd usually be
like five ten minutes it took a little
bit longer 15 minutes today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
what if I just check on check and see
how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it we're gonna we gotta change
it we gotta go we gotta make some
content you're gonna do this and make
that first video so even for me even for
someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I sit in front of the camera
to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it the
difference is how quickly can you shift
how can you get unstuck
because most people just stay stuck they
stay constipated they're like all this
all the stuff that has to come out
that's just not coming out
you're constipated
so how do you do it how do you shift it
here are a couple things that helped me
that I hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
people don't want to floss I mean my
floss I've built the habit of flossing
twice a day most people don't floss and
the concept is just floss one tooth and
once you've floss one tooth you'll floss
the rats probably right just get your
running shoes on and go for a walk and
once you're walking you'll probably do
more than you know the two minutes that
you set yourself into mind like just do
two minutes so for me is just make the
first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing
come on
just keep going just just go it's so
much easier to keep the momentum going
once you've built some momentum the
hardest step is the first step the
hardest step is just building that
initial momentum at the beginning once
you get going it's a lot easier to keep
going so just start don't don't make it
some big thing they'll make it some
giant Endeavor that you have to go off
and Chase it's nice to have big goals
and big Ambitions and Big Dreams but
sometimes they're too big and then you
feel like you can't do it and you need
venture capital and you need a team and
you need all sorts of things before you
can do anything on it it's great to have
that big goal and what are you gonna do
today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building up momentum
it's just so much so much so much so
much easier so the challenge for today
is just just find one small simple easy
way to get started it doesn't have to be
amazing it doesn't have to be great it's
just the first step
once you get your first step it's so
much easier to take the second so that's
one just start building some immediate
momentum number two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if this
feels more conversational I don't know
game
if it feels more I feel like I'm talking
to a friend hello how you doing I'm Evan
it feels it feels more conversational
and natural for me I like having the sun
on my face you know it just feels better
and so changing your state can be a good
way if you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
really helps I promise you have you ever
had a uh you're thinking really
negatively
you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room where you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus
for that is music music I should have
done that today music is
the fastest way to change your state so
while I was sitting here in the car for
15 minutes procrastinating and making
these videos instead of thinking hey I
should go and check in on my team and
see how they're doing underneath like
logically that makes sense like how's my
team doing I'm being a good boss you
know good manager a good friend I should
check in on them see how they're doing
it's going to move my goals forward of
course because if they're waiting on me
for something right logically all that
makes sense underneath it is just again
the fear that my videos won't be good
enough so I need to feel productive I
need to feel value valuable to myself I
need to feel worthy so I'm going to
spend my time there instead of making
videos right I should have put on music
when that was happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to
uh I should have put on some music
put on some music that makes you move
and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple of
them from my example in my office I have
five pictures on the wall and they all
tell a different story remind me of who
I want to be I've got Steve Jobs on the
wall who reminds me to be a Visionary
I've got AP giannini on the wall who's
my favorite entrepreneur of all time and
he reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest Meme and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting
the crime of lack of belief
right and and so just somebody commented
on my hoodie yesterday's like you're
always wearing you're always on brand
you're always wearing your hoodie it's
like it's not just it's not just when I
show up to make videos this is this is
this is what I wear because I'm a I'm a
superhero going to work and when I put
this on in the morning it's like I'm I'm
I'm Batman going to work or uh uh you
know police officer going to work it's
like this is this is what I do and
I'm a lot more for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
and so as a conscious choice to say okay
what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that you ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is that this is who I want to
be this is who I want to be this is who
I want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say yeah you you can't do that and
here's all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons you are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid they're going to be judged we're
afraid of disappointing people we're
afraid of not being loved we're afraid
that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in 6 months and 12 months you can
it's possible you can your mission is
worthy and Noble and should happen and
you're the one to do it you you're the
one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum you just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step discipline is your missing
ingredient you've got the heart you've
got the care you've got the desire to
serve you know you could be doing more
you want to do it for the right reasons
you're not just here to make money
you're here to have an impact in the
grow and do amazing things you know you
can do amazing things what's missing
discipline
this is a lack of follow-through it's
the constant start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reasons why I'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post to my
socials of how I grew month over month
year over year on YouTube and in the
first five years I had 7 000 subscribers
or so
five years in five years in of making
content
7 000 subscribers a lot of you are
already ahead of that a lot of you could
get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
in 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and insecure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
beliefs all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me
I remember sitting down at a
Florida outlet mall and I was sitting
there with uh with a friend and Nina was
going shopping and uh we spent half an
hour at a at a Starbucks there while she
was shopping and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee of my mystery it was in
music I'm gonna be the next garyvee in
music and uh
You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
let's me you know let's let's keep in
touch and see how we do and how we grow
and he posted
you know three or four years later
on his Instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as
the as the post and I told him I was
gonna be the next garyvee for music and
he's gonna do keep doing his thing and
and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped
I didn't have the success that I said I
was gonna have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more Talent than I do and he's super
talented in music and just better camera
presence
more energy
uh more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had all of
this stuff and and like a warm amazing
human who cares and wants to serve and
wants to see musicians make money and
turn their art into something amazing
right like he had all of this stuff all
of it
the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I
see that in so many of you
've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the lack of because you're
not motivated you stop and lack of
motivation isn't a good enough reason
you have to follow through
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there from the moment you wake up before
you've even gotten up there's a whole
bunch of people out there who have an
idea for what you should do with your
day whether it's your friends or your
family or your co-workers or your boss
or your team or your employees or your
customer